10 28 janvier les nouvelles mesures
attendues contre le coc vie 19 feront
l'objet d'un débat et d'un vote à
l'assemblée et au sénat la semaine
prochaine alors que l'efficacité du
couvre feu c'est ce temps selon olivier
ferrand qui parle d'épidémie dans
l'épidémie si nous ne faisons rien le
porte parole du gouvernement évoque de
son côté lui l'allongement des vacances
de février
sans certitude pour l'instant les
restrictions sanitaires qui pousse à
mouler libanais certains se retrouvent
sans aucun revenu depuis l'imposition du
confinement
le pays du cèdre où l'on craint ce soir
une quatrième nuit d'émeutes
consécutives alors que les ong amnesty
international épingle paris sur l' usage
de ses armes dans la répression à
beyrouth autres défiance celle de la
population tunisienne envers le nouvel
exécutif un remaniement gouvernementale
menée par le premier ministre contesté
par une grande partie de la rue ainsi
que par le président du pays
c'est dans ce contexte que kaïs saïd a
reçu un courrier suspect une enquête a
été ouverte
[Musique]
les nouvelles mesures attendues pour
freiner l'épidémie ducobu 19 feront donc
l'objet d'un débat et d'un vote à
l'assemblée et au sénat la semaine
prochaine annonce au soir de plusieurs
responsables politiques qui ont
participé à une réunion avec le premier
ministre jean castex
un peu plus tôt dans la journée olivier
verront en lui s'est exprimée pas de
grandes annonces variant réanimation
couvre-feu autant de sujets abordés pour
selon lui expliquer les futures mesures
mises en place par le gouvernement
le couvre-feu qui n'est pas suffisamment
efficace pour freiner la progression de
l'épidémie selon le ministre de la santé
je ne rentre pas dans des listes de
chiffres trop là où nous avons mis en
place un couvre-feu à 18h30 au tout
début du mois de janvier
il ya d'abord eu un effet réel de baisse
de la pression épidémique
puis une stabilisation dans le reste du
pays là où il n'y avait pas de couvre
feu au tout début du mois de janvier
l'épidémie a été un peu plus forte ces
dernières semaines ce qui veut dire que
globalement le couvre-feu à 18h à une
efficacité probablement at il permis que
nous évitions de connaître la même vague
épidémique que nombre de nos voisins
mais à l'évidence cette efficacité
s'estompe et à l'évidence cela ne suffit
pas à faire reculer le virus alors
êtes-vous prêt un éventuel nouveau
confinement s'il était instaurée c'est
la question que nous avons posée dans la
rue alors je suis pour la prudence donc
s'il le faut oui en effet je serais pour
un troisième confinement malheureusement
pour les commerces c'est dramatique mais
il est préférable quand même de de
préserver la santé des gens c'est pour
le bien public on va dire y'a pas de
soucis mais bon là les personnes en fait
tout autour de nous elles ont marre
raisonnons marre de ça dans d'autres
pays c'est mieux gérer et je pense que
le gouvernement devrait revoir un peu
ses priorités faso coronavirus
psychologiquement ça commence à être dur
déjà là le couvre-feu 18 heures c'est un
peu violent troisième confinement déjà
le deuxième il m'a un peu abattu mois
donc non pas de troisième fois finement
il ya du travail je travaille plus je
fais plus rien donc ça ferait du bien
que ça recommence pas je suis vraiment
chercher de l'aide
tellement c'est le bordel je m'en
rendais pas compte que j'étais un peu
trop égoïste je pensais que ça touchait
que moi mais apparemment je crois que ça
bouge pas mal de demanderait en partie
ma tranche d'âge ce que j'ai confiance
en l'avenir mais
mais là dans le chai inquiet pour le
présent c'est déjà énorme autant comme
le premier parce que le deuxième pour
ceux qui travaillent nous ça change rien
les gens ils continuent à sortir à cette
fois qu'on a bien vu les chiffres sur le
premier confinement ça réduit
drastiquement les chiffres alors que le
deuxième a repris quoi par exemple cet
été là on est quasiment pas de cas parce
qu'on sortait du premier confinement et
en était un
on était tous chez nous d'ailleurs choix
que la france n'ait rien seul pays qui
marche comme ça en angleterre c'est
confinement total donc comme le premier
où personne sort de chez lui après ils
ont des chiffres qui sont quand même
plus élevé que les autres mais moi je
pense que si c'est nécessaire autant
confinés comme le premier conte et le
ministre de la santé en quelque sorte
préparer les esprits au durcissement des
mesures sanitaires des mesures de plus
en plus mal vécue par les français ce
qui pose des difficultés à l'exécutif
alors qu'elle confinement adopter
comment faire passer la pilule alors que
le gouvernement craint son dos des
manifestations anti restrictions à
l'instar des pays bas du danemark ou de
l'espagne place à notre décryptage
[Musique]
les pourparlers nous sommes avec cécile
riz la députée la république en marche
troisième circonscription du val d'oise
jean frédéric poisson président du parti
via la voix du peuple
stéphane lenny golts restaurateurs porte
parole du mouvement restons ouverts
bonsoir à tous les trois merci beaucoup
d'être en direct avec nous alors on a
bien compris en ce sont les variants
l'inquiétude numéro un du gouvernement
on rappelle quelques chiffres plus de
2000 patients par jour toucher désormais
par un variant olivier ferrand qui a
fait le point sur l'épidémie le premier
le ministre de la santé qui n'était pas
vraiment optimiste on les écoute avant
de vous faire réagir
globalement le couvre-feu à 18h à une
efficacité probablement at il permis que
nous évitions de connaître la même vague
épidémique que nombre de nos voisins
mais à l'évidence cette efficacité
s'estompe et à l'évidence cela ne suffit
pas à faire reculer le virus je peux
vous citer des exemples d'hôpitaux qui
procède actuellement à des transferts de
patients de réanimation au sein d'une
région c'est le cas notamment de nice
qui est obligé de transférer des malades
parce qu'ils ont trop de malades qui
arrivent en service de réanimation
je vous parlais de la région grand est
de bourgogne franche comté ou des
hôpitaux font face à des fortes tensions
dans les service de réa dans les
services d'accueil des urgences et des
hôpitaux et nous ne sommes pas très loin
d'envisager à nouveau de procéder aux
premiers transferts de patients inter
régionaux pour soulager certaines
régions nous sommes presque à 60 %
d'occupation des lits de réanimation par
des patients atteints de corona des
russes donc non la tension hospitalière
elle est réelle a plein de mauvaises
nouvelles à cela gabriel atta le porte
parole du gouvernement qui rajoutait que
le maintien du cadre actuel paraissait
peu probable la majorité clairement nous
prépare psychologiquement un troisième
confinement cécile heures et là tu es à
je ne sais pas si la majorité prépare
cela une chose est sûre c'est que moi
dans mon département dans ma
circonscription ça fait des jours où je
j'entends mes concitoyens m'appeler me
demander s'il va y avoir un troisième
confinement donc c'est véritablement un
sujet et comme le disait certaines
personnes interviewées dans votre
portage moi je sens monter une réelle
angoisse de la part de mes concitoyens
s'il devait y avoir un troisième
confinement donc vous comprenez bien que
dans ces conditions le gouvernement et
qu'ils consultent énormément un pas
seulement non médical mais qui consulte
également les élus les élus locaux les
parlementaires les corps intermédiaires
va vraiment prendre une décision la plus
la salle on ne pourra pas reculer
c'est ça que ces sacs importante pour
l'instant nous aussi on attend les le
discours du premier ministre donc la
semaine prochaine il nous a annoncé un
débat à l'assemblée nationale avec un
vote
donc ça veut dire en effet qu'il va y
avoir de nouveau des décisions
importantes à pro mais ça on l'avait
justement compris stéphane manigold il
n'est pas là aussi le problème il ya le
problème évidemment d'un confinement
craint par les français mais aussi celui
de de ne pas être prévenus à temps parce
que c'est vrai qu'il ya par exemple
beaucoup de parents qui attendent pour
organiser les vacances scolaires c'est
très compliqué on le sait quand on
travaille et qu'on a des enfants
est-ce qu'on n'attend pas un petit peu
trop quand même le dernier moment on
attend oui trop dernier moment on nous
prend un peu pour des enfants et on est
dans le manque d'anticipation total le
président république avait indiqué
qu'ils allaient 66 millions de
procureurs non il ya 66 millions d'êtres
humains d'individus qui travaillent qui
sont parents qui emmènent leurs enfants
à l'école et chefs d'entreprise qui
vivent dans l'angoissé parce que chaque
semaine eh bien il ya des échéances
supplémentaire des dates qui n'arrivent
pas à des ouvertures qu'il n'arrive pas
et
c'est ce manque de lisibilité
aujourd'hui qui fait défaut aux 66
millions français il y a une espèce
d'anxiété et là pour le coup est bien
vous faites pas votre travail pardon
madame la députée de vous le dire mais
et vous fait pas le job parce que les
français et françaises ont besoin d'être
rassurés ce ne sont pas des enfants ils
n'ont pas besoin de câlinothérapie
ils ont besoin et bien d'avoir un cap
une orientation une définition d'une
politique de vaccination claire précise
et sans couac une accélération sur le
sujet vous avez des millions de
personnes qui ne travaillent pas
aujourd'hui alors oui ces personnes nos
salariés sont protégés sont sont
rémunérés nos entreprises sortent à
peine le nez de l'eau pas la tête mais
le nez de l'eau la bouche reste toujours
sous l'eau et puis vous avez madame
borgne pour reprendre et pour parler de
nos amis de la montagne qui a indiqué
aux saisonniers et bien aux citations ce
qui est de recruter des salariés ce
qu'ils ont fait est bien le reste à
charge il y est pas parce que eh bien
les saisonniers comme vous le savez en
montagne sont hébergés ils sont logés et
c'est tout un pan de l'économie qui est
en train de massacrer al rien dialogue
avec bercy faut le souligner il ya un
dialogue et bruno le maire y ait un
dialogue carlingue brisée
mais je vais vous poser une question
assez directe madame la députée si
demain à l'assemblée nationale il y a un
projet de loi qui vous est présentée
concernant l'indemnisation au réel du
préjudice subi par les entreprises sans
faute de l'état 1 dans le monde entier
il est un confinement est ce que vous
serez prêt à voter c'est indemnisation
réel pour les entreprises parce que vous
nous connais de la dette aujourd'hui
sans qu'on soit en capacité de main de
la rembourser le prêt garanti par l'état
c'est un prêt et comme vous le savez
pour pouvoir un moment rembourser un
prêt et bien il faut qu'on gagne un tout
petit peu d'argent envoyés pour pouvoir
faire face à ses dépenses auxquelles
nous ne pourrons pas faire face donc ma
question est simple même les députés
est ce que si demain à l'assemblée
nationale vous ai présenté un projet de
loi visant à indemniser les entreprises
durablement frappé par cette crise est
fermé
par l'état est-ce que vous mettrez un
amendement qui qui va dans ce sens alors
on va laisser répondre cécile relax
rapidement avant de laisser aussi la
parole à jean frédéric poisson qui pour
l'instant n'a pas parlé cécile relax sur
la question clairement posée alors avant
répondants cette question clairement
posée deux remarques non d'anticipation
le problème aujourd'hui c'est que
comment vous voulez anticipées lorsque
il n'y a pas de visibilité alors à moins
d'avoir une boule de cristal
on ne peut pas anticiper donc on est
obligé de prendre des décisions par
rapport à des chiffres et par rapport à
une situation
cette situation aujourd'hui on est en
train de voir qu'il y avait un plateau
que ce plateau augmente malgré le
confinement que ce plateau augmente
malgré les mesures et
il va falloir enrayer l'épidémie est en
fait c'est une course qui est en train
de se passer entre le variant même les
variantes puisqu'aujourd'hui nous en
sommes à trois et les la campagne de
vaccination là où vous dit également
qu'il n'y a pas de cap de fixer je suis
désolé monsieur le cap sur la politique
vaccinale
elle est très très bien fixée elle est
très claire depuis le mois de décembre
donc là dessus nous n'avons jamais
dérogé au calendrier vaccinal je dirais
même que par rapport aux annonces du
mois de décembre
nous sommes même en avance sur le
calendrier matinale qui avait été prévu
et qui avait été présenté d'ailleurs
devant l'assemblée nationale par le
premier ministre donc là dessus euh je
peux pas vous laisser dire qu'il n'y a
pas de cap qu'il n'y a pas de visibilité
nous savons exactement où nous allons au
niveau du calendrier fixe à fixe et jean
quant à votre dernière question il y a
juste un petit paradoxe dans ce que vous
dites c'est que d'un côté vous me
demander de voter un amendement pour une
même dénomination une indemnisation sur
l'économie et sur les entreprises et
d'un autre côté vous le dites que la
dette elles font si jamais vous lui
demander de voter une indemnisation est
ce que j'ai noté une indemnisation
coûtant pour toutes les entreprises
ça veut dire que ça sera l'état qui
paiera et donc ça serait une
augmentation de la dette nationale
donc va aujourd'hui oui on va on va
donner pardonnez moi on a compris en
tout cas voilà au 7e rang européen
on va laisser aussi répondu jean
frédéric poisson qui faisaient les gros
yeux en compte et des côtes et madame la
députée s'exprimer sur l'anticipation
jean frédéric poisson
bonjour à tous et merci à notre
invitation jeu il se trouve que je sais
un peu d'expérience que de temps en
temps être un député de la majorité
parlementaire ce n'est pas facile
il a visiblement ça se vérifie que
j'étais fière je suis un de vos
confrères avec un des collègues de
madame ria qu'il était le pauvre dans un
sale état
les français ne peuvent pas entendre ça
cette espèce de supplice chinois de
torture qu'on nous inflige depuis deux
semaines trois semaines un mois il y
aura t'il eu rend-il pas de confinement
il faut être confortablement installé
dans sa vie personnelle pour n'être pas
impactés par comment dire cette ces
annonces à répétition qui ne nous
permettent jamais ni de prévoir ni
d'organiser quoi que ce soit mais ne met
pas simplement sur le plan professionnel
et pas simplement comme quand on est
comme c'est mon cas d'ailleurs un
travailleur indépendant ou en chefs de
petites entreprises comme c'est le cas
de du collègue aux restaurateurs qui est
avec nous donc sur le ton de la
communication la gestion de cette étude
catastrophe
une pure catastrophe quand j'entends
madame le député richard collègues je
suis désolé de vous le dire que vous
êtes en avance sur les annonces faites
sur deux axes enfin hier il y avait six
mille personnes vaccinées en france où
montant des 6000 personnes ont reçu les
deux doses
vous ne pouvez pas décemment oui un
million de personnes ont reçu la
première dose et sur le million 6000 en
tulle et docile 2016 la santé donc à ce
rythme là il faudra à peu près peut-être
trois siècles et demi pour vacciner
l'ensemble des français ça n'est pas
sérieux
mais par ailleurs j'entends que
l'interdiction faite aux médecins
comment dire de de traiter de
d'administrer les traitements dont ils
ont prouvé l'efficacité dans leur
cabinet tout cela continue d'être
ennuyés donc je dis simplement sur le
plan de la communication cette gestion
est une catastrophe sur le plan de la
stratégie de santé publique cette
gestion de crise est une catastrophe
et c'est pourquoi je dis que le
couvre-feu écoutez j'ai entendu le j'ai
entendu le ministre la santé dire que le
couvre feu était efficace dans des
endroits où il était appliqué à 18
heures madame le député vous habitez le
val d'oise je crois donc en
ile-de-france comme moi à quelques
dizaines de kilomètres de paris
vous avez vu 0 voitures sur les
autoroutes quand vous rentrez chez vous
à 18h bien sûr que non c'est une farce
il ya des centaines de milliers de
francs si bien qu'ils ne respectaient
pas le couvre feu parce qu'ils ne
peuvent pas faire autrement et il ya des
millions de français les millions de
français qui sont dans cette situation
de ne pas être en capacité simplement
parce qu'ils veulent survivre de
respecter les consignes idiote que le
gouvernement envoie à l'ensemble de la
population dans le troisième pour filmer
ça va exploser je vous le dis et si ça
n'explose pas dans la rue ce qui n'est
pas mon score ça explosera dans la tête
des gens parce que on fabrique depuis le
mois de juin je suis le monde du travail
depuis longtemps et je parle avec les
organisations syndicales des
professionnels depuis très longtemps
depuis le mode mans on a alerté sur les
conditions dans lesquelles le
télétravail pouvait bouleversé esquinté
psychologiquement les travailleurs qui
sont concernés donc ce n'est pas une
nouvelle on se réveille maintenant dix
ans à il ya peut-être une crise
psychologique qui nous attend celui de
pardonnez moi jean frédéric 300 points
pour avancer dans le débat pour rebondir
surtout sur ce que vous
venez de dire regardez ce sondage cette
idée voulez vous avez raison de 3e
confinement ne plaît pas beaucoup aux
français cet institut de sondage et lab
sur l'acceptation des français depuis le
début de la crise il ya bientôt donc un
an c'est un petit peu la dégringolade
93% des français étaient favorables au
premier confinement en mars dernier 67 %
lors du deuxième le 29 octobre dernier
et seulement un français sur deux
aujourd'hui alors pour rebondir sur ce
que disait jean frédéric poisson ces six
là qu est ce que vous craignez à la
majorité une révolte à l'instar de ce
qui se passe notamment aux pays bas au
danemark ou en espagne est ce que
l'exécutif est clairement inquiet
aujourd'hui
moi j'ai pas parlé pour l'exécutif
bourse de paris pourrait tourner là nous
sommes alors la même farine
personnellement en tant que député de la
majorité
c'est ce que je disais dès le début et
c'est pour ça qu'avec monsieur poisson
là dessus on est d'accord parce que moi
j'entends bien aussi cette angoisse est
justement les retours de terrain que je
fais au gouvernement pour qu'il puisse
prendre sa décision
c'est que cette tension psychologique
cette angoisse elle est réelle et que en
effet je confirme que il y a aujourd'hui
le 3ème confinement n'est pas acceptée
aujourd'hui par une grande partie de la
population et particulièrement par les
personnes qui ont l'impression d'avoir
déjà beaucoup donné et particulièrement
notre jeunesse
donc c'est no c'est mon boulot de
députés de faire remonter aussi des
informations qui qui qui qui sont la
réalité
après il faudra prendre les décisions et
on est là pour prendre des décisions les
meilleures possibles de manière à ce que
madame la discussion est juste un risque
de crise sociale énorme comme vous
l'avez dit aussi avec des personnes qui
sont dans une situation psychologique
très très inconfortable et il ne
faudrait pas rajouter à une situation
sociale à une situation sanitaire
difficile
un problème de crise économique derrière
stefan mani goal c'est même la députée
madame la députée lorsque vous êtes
exprimés vous m'appelle vous m'avez
parlé comme un opposant politique
moi je suis chef d'entreprise j'ai un
collectif qui s'appelle restons ouverts
et ça fait des mois
madame la députée que nous appelons à
l'unité et que le gouvernement les élus
nous écoute parce que nous sommes forts
de proposition et lorsque je vous
entends dire avec une forme de mépris
pardon j'ai pas de boule de cristal moi
non plus j'ai pas de boule de cristal
en revanche chez un chef d'entreprise et
diriger c'est prévoir et lorsque le 7
janvier
j'annonce qu'il ya un troisième
confinement c'est pas parce que j'ai vu
dans une boule de cristal
c'est juste que hélas ce virus y sévit
dans le monde entier et j'observe
comment y circulent en allemagne comment
y circulent au royaume-uni et dirige et
c'est aussi prévoir est bien gouverné
madame la députée c'est aussi prévoir et
quand le 7 des 11 janvier
j'annonce le troisième le confinement à
l'anglais c'est parce que j'observe
quand le 24 septembre avait que votre
confrère sylvain maillard respectable
puisqu'il est chef d'entreprise en plus
députés que vous connaissez très bien
le 24 septembre j'annonce le deuxième
confinement
non pas parce que j'ai une boule de
cristal mais parce que simplement à
nouveau ce sont des statistiques et je
sais lire des statistiques et jolie
quotidiennement les rapports de santé
publique france donc ya pas besoin de
boule de cristal pour diriger une
entreprise n'y a pas deux en boule de
cristal pour digérer impayés il suffit
simplement d'observer ce qui se passe
ailleurs et qu'ensemble on s'écoute et
qu'on arrête de se parler comme des
opposants y compris là pour les
opposants politiques c'est facile parce
que moi la politique l'a fait dans les
urnes quand je vote là aujourd'hui je
protège et j'essaie de protéger et vers
si vous m'avez pas entendu tout à
l'heure mais je le répète vers ci est à
nos côtés
bruno le maire est à nos côtés alain
griset est à nos côtés il nous soutient
mais moi je vous le dis il n'y a pas
qu'eux qui doivent nous soutenir les
députés et vous êtes dans un département
l'oise qui est lourdement touchée par
cette crise il ya là matière dans ses
vertes années moi je vous coupe mais il
faut aller plus vite parce qu'on a
encore plusieurs idées à vous faire
réagir clairement vont pour on compte ce
confinement et on donnera la parole à
jean frédéric poisson pour on compte ce
troisième confie de monstres et
économiquement moralement absolument
contre scientifiquement je ne suis pas
un virologue ça il appartient aux
professionnels de santé d'établir les
raisons de ce confinement jeune frédéric
poisson justement pour vous faire réel
surnom ces français qui semble être
plutôt contre en tout cas il y en a un
sur deux aujourd'hui vous vous appelez
clairement la désobéissance civile
oui je crois que nous sommes entrés dans
une période où à lire un certain nombre
de deux circulaires ou de décret est
publié par le gouvernement sur le
rabotage des libertés fondamentales à
voir combien les mesures restrictives de
nos libertés y compris d'ailleurs la
liberté d'entreprendre et de travailler
qui est ô combien impact est aujourd'hui
de manière parfaitement disproportionnée
par rapport
pas forcément par rapport à la situation
sanitaire mais par rapport à ce qu'on
pourrait faire de manière différente
la perspective de voir que tous les
français seraient un nouveau confinés
chez eux est quelque chose qui me paraît
relever de l'oppression pure et simple
j'ajoute que ce n'est pas notre débat
d'aujourd'hui mais quand je vois qu
arrive sur le bureau du conseil d'état
puis les gouvernements des décrets
concernant le fisc le fichage sur les
questions de radicalisation ou encore
des restrictions de liberté de circuler
de culte vetsera je me dis que petit à
petit nous entrons dans un système à
cause de la situation sanitaire très
disproportionnée en matière de liberté
donc pour moi qui te précise et quand le
système est possible quand par ailleurs
on sait bien qu'il y aurait une autre
façon de procéder sur le plan médical et
scientifique et ben moi je suis comme ce
baragouin super médecin mais j'ai
l'habitude des signes et d'écouté comme
vous d'ailleurs on s'en doute l'ensemble
des opinions qui circulent et je suis
très frappé de voir le nombre de
médecins qui disent mais ne craignez pas
une saturation des lits de réanimation
nous savons comment traiter dako vide en
année donc arretez de dire que la
stratégie vaccinale unique est le remède
absolu ça n'est pas vrai donc si
effectivement il y a cette capacité de
traitement que des médecins aux mises au
point qui fonctionne qui guérissent les
passions si effectivement on s'est
impliqué dans tous les établissements de
restauration de france et de navarre nez
avec sanitaires est absurde
on a fait ça comment dire pendant les
périodes qui de l'automne mais tous les
restaurateurs que je connais ont
appliqué sa très tranquillement il a été
parfaitement montré que ce n'est pas les
restaurants qui sont à l'origine de la
remontée de l'épidémie où il n'ya pas de
kloster de restauration tout ça n'existe
pas les stands des restaurateurs comme
g20 pourrait parler
accusés d'être des classes tard
exactement c'est tout à fait ça donc si
vous voulez on sait bien les français
sont grands ils sont responsables si
vous leur est donné le soin là où ils
sont d'ordinaire choses de manière
intelligente de manière respectueuse ils
feront attention à la propre santé parce
qu'ils sont pas fous ne visitera de
droit de vous couper j'aime pas ça mais
c'est vrai que chacun s'exprime très
loin du conte à on a du mal à faire
avancer les idées parce que je voudrais
qu'on termine ce débat avec la fin de la
mission qu vide à l'assemblée nationale
je vais vous redonner la parole mais par
parler peut-être plus rapidement tous
les trois s'il vous plaît la mission
coville à l'assemblée nationale qui a
été dissous décision annoncée hier et
qui a provoqué la colère des députés de
l'opposition avant de vous faire réagir
et goûter celle de jean luc mélenchon
damien abad et olivier faur la mission
parlementaire de suivi de la crise qu
vide est arbitrairement dissous deux
privant le parlement de son pouvoir de
contrôle
c'est une trahison démocratique nous
sommes en train d'assister à
l'enterrement de première classe de la
mission d'information sur la corrida
l'assemblée nationale et ceci en pleine
crise sanitaire
c'est un naufrage démocratique
totalement surréaliste alors que le
sénat va lancer la sienne
ici elle s'arrête scandaleux en marche
dissous la commission denquête de
l'assemblée nationale sur la gestion de
la crise sanitaire par le gouvernement
contre l'avis de toute l'opposition
macron et ses ministres ont peur
d'assumer publiquement leur politique
hasardeuse maladresse trois minutes on
va essayer de se distribuer la parole
chacun cécile relax votre réaction une
trahison démocratique
non ce sont les règles c'est à dire que
une mission parlementaire ces six mois
et il ya justement eu un rapport qui a
été émis quelle est la part de monsieur
sottil mon collègue julien borowitz qui
était le président justement de cette
mission parlementaire dont classe ne
s'est pas un déni de démocratie
c'est que c'est simplement les
applications du fonctionnement de
l'assemblée nationale donc la mission
parlementaire elle elle a eu son temps
donc par contre tous les collègues
de l'opposition s'ils le veulent ils
peuvent toujours demander une commission
d'enquêté n'y a aucun souci
c'est ce qu'on appelle le droit de
tirage nous sommes en 2021
donc si jamais que ce soit monsieur
mélenchon monsieur forme sur la bad
s'ils veulent de nouveau ouvrir une
commission enquête sur ce sujet ils le
peuvent tout à fait donc il n'y a aucun
déni démocratique
stéphane manigold le citoyen que vous
êtes attendait quelque chose de cette
commission
ça c'est de la politique d'oslo délaisse
discutent entre eux par contre je vais
juste l'utiliser une seconde de mon
temps de parole pour dire que 1 au
collectif nous ne sommes pas pour l'un
c'est rue l'insurrection
c'est dire est citoyenne ou je ne sais
quoi ça c'est non et 2 concernant je
dirais les le confinement je veux juste
apporter un variable
oui pour un confinement si le président
de la république fixe un cap avec une
vision claire et un objectif non si
c'est pour nous laisser à la maison
regarder netflix et nous tourner les
pouces
le mot de la fin pour vous jean frédéric
poisson
monsieur va mieux la désobéissance
civile ça n'est pas l'insurrection
la désobéissance civile elle est un
droit constitutionnel reconnu par le
conseil constitutionnel
il y as mais oui madame le député vous
vérifierez vous même reconnu par le
conseil constitutionnel manière tout à
fait formels il est le moyen qui est
donnée au peuple de dire au pouvoir
exécutif qui ne l'entend pas il doit
changer de trajectoire ne s'agit pas
d'aller cassé des abribus
il s'agit d'aller soutenir en
désobéissant aux réglementations idiote
de soutenir des gens qui désobéissent
réglementation idiote je répète de gier
a déjà démarré un virus qui tue oui non
mais bien l'institut oui d'accord
enfin il ya aussi des gens qui meurent
et des restaurateurs qui ferme qu'ils
n'oublieront pas et je ne parle pas de
tous les autres commerces des nerfs la
vie de tous les jours défendez pas
messieurs je vous le faites de manière
professionnelle bas je le fais du point
de vue des responsabilités politiques
chacun son boulot comme vous l'avez très
bien dit mais ça laisse de simplement si
les gens comme moi ne vont pas soutenir
des restaurateurs qui ouvre le 1er
février mais resteront fermés c'est tout
ce que je dis et si on fait pas parler
dans des commerces qui lit des attaques
restaurateur vosgien qui s'est suicidé
parce qu'il a pris une fermeture
administrative
il faut quand même et indiqué qu'ils
s'exposent à de lourdes sanctions
donc moi de toute façon des restaurants
sont déjà ouverts j'ai pas attendu le
1er février parce qu'on est opposés à
faire du click and collect tout
simplement ce que je ne veux pas c'est
que les restaurants ouvrent avec des
clients à table moi je n'appelle pas à
de la désobéissance qui générerait des
drames bien pire qu'ils ne le sont déjà
actuellement
merci à tous les trois c'est sillery
laquelle jean frédéric poisson et
stéphane manigold avoir été avec nous en
direct et dans quelques instants rester
avec nous nous partirons au liban où des
manifestations éclatent depuis le début
de la semaine à cause du confinement
dans un pays déjà affaibli
économiquement
direction ensuite à tunisie où les
tensions sont vives également avec des
protestations contre le nouvel exécutif
[Musique]
vous insistez beaucoup sur l'aspect des
dépenses publiques ce que je critique
c'est que on est dans un état
d'addiction de grande dépendance à la
dépense publique je ne veux pas du sang
et des larmes le sang et les larmes on
les a déjà trop de dépenses trop d'état
je pense en tout cas qu'il ya trop de
bureaucratie c'est à dire un état
inefficace tout ça a été financée
essentiellement par de la dette
le problème est moins la dette en
réalité moi je pense qu'on remboursera
la dette par la crise
donc il faut essayer de libérer
l'économie française et notamment le
travail
notre problème en france c'est un
problème où la dépense publique et est
excessive
mais surtout elle n'est pas productive
les français n'en ont pas pour leur
argent
de ce point de vue à emmanuel macron n'a
rien changé par exemple par rapport à
son prédécesseur françois hollande
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chaque jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs se jouer mais les
règles ne sont pas toujours respectées
les couleurs changent de camp les pions
prennent la place des rois de fismes
stratégies peuvent porter des résultats
inattendus
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire
je suis allée de chômeurs et chaque
semaine dans l'échiquier mondial nous
analyserons les coups les plus complexes
du jeu politique internationale
[Musique]
à bientôt sur rt france
20h30 soit les bienvenus en direct sur
rt français vous nous rejoignez la crise
sanitaire couplée d'une triple crise
politique économique et sociale au liban
où l'on craint ce soir une quatrième
nuit de violences à l'origine des
manifestations qui durent depuis
maintenant trois jours le confinement
qui accentue la pauvreté au moins un
manifestant a été tué hier soit plus de
200 blessées à tripoli dans le nord du
pays et coûté ces réactions de liben et
consterné ils nous ont ruiné ils nous
ont transformés en mendiants
on n'a plus les moyens de manger les
gens meurent les gens manche qu'il
trouve dans les poubelles
vous voulez acheter à manger et nourrir
vos enfants vous ne pouvez pas ils nous
ont détruits d'aoulef les tailles
corrompu l'état est une ordure l'état
nous a rabaissés au plus bas l'état
autorisé des fêtes pour le nouvel an et
à gagner des millions ils ont fait la
fête
ils ont terminé puis ils nous ont dit
coronavirus et ont fermé les magasins
nous n'avons rien à manger un ananas et
le liban où la france est pointée du
doigt par amnesty international pour l'
usage de ses armes dans la répression
des manifestants selon les ong des
armements de fabrication française ont
été utilisées pour réprimer les
militants il s'agit de grenades
lacrymogènes de balles en caoutchouc ou
encore de lance-grenades l'organisation
non gouvernementale se base notamment
sur une centaine de vidéos de
manifestations qui ont lieu en 2015 en
2019 mais aussi en 2020 la france
fournit depuis des années aux forces de
sécurité libanaises des équipements de
maintien de l'ordre dont elles se
servent ensuite pour commettre ou
facilité de graves violations des droits
humains
nous appelons la france à veiller à ce
que les ventes soient suspendues jusqu'à
ce que les autorités libanaises
reconnaissent des atteintes commises par
le passé et pour en parler nous sommes
en direct depuis beyrouth avec antoine
sfeir avocat à paris et beyrouth
professeur de droit international à
l'université saint joseph de beyrouth
c'est notre rôle
vu de l'extérieur ce soir bonsoir
antoine sfeir merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france la répression
alimentée par le made in france c'est la
formule que l'on retrouve clairement sur
le site d'amnesty international qui
accuse donc paris on l'a entendu de
contribuer aux violences à hong kong et
en fournisseur d'armes votre réaction à
ces accusations des ong en premier c'est
demain tout ce qui se passe au liban
spécialement c'était les geôles à
tripoli dans le nord du liban il ya des
problèmes majeurs des problèmes de santé
de des problèmes de dos voté il ya la
qualité des services publics qui est en
état de désarroi
il ya tout un système qui s'écoule par
contrôler la justice sociale n'existe
plus tout ça a engendré une certaine
révolution pacifique s'était 2009 le
jeudi 7 octobre 2010 mme du helmand et
des problèmes qui ont commencé deux
nouveaux dans l'est de tripoli et qui
peuvent être vraiment généralisée dans
tous les
toutes les régions du pays vu que les
problèmes sont toujours là que les
problèmes de sociaux c'est à dire qu'il
ya des gens qui n'ont plus de quoi
manger
c'est un grand problème il n'y a pas de
solution en vue il ya toujours des
discours des choses qui sont pas qu'ils
sont faits qui ne donne plus rien aux
compatriotes libanais le citoyen s'avère
vraiment bel essai c'est pour cela
actuellement il ya un
si vous voulez une équation de forces de
l'ordre viennent de tripoli entre les
forces de la sec de sécurité intérieure
et les les les citoyens et manifestants
le problème ici c'est dommage que
linguistique international qui est qui
n'est pas une organisation onusienne
mais c'est une organisation
c'est une organisation
non-gouvernementale internationalement
reconnu quelques échecs qu'est laquelle
a décrit la situation au liban
de cette façon si depuis 2015
ça ne veut pas dire que tout les toutous
les fêtes qui qu'on a vu dans le rapport
de l'ars international son vrai il ya
une certaine véracité des choses qui
doivent être faites par via une enquête
l enquête que les pouvoirs libanais au
plus ou plutôt des organisations
internationales ou même libanaise quinté
pendant qu'ils doivent le faire afin de
sauvegarder en premier les libertés
publiques en second la crédibilité des
forces des forces de la vie et des des
institutions libanaises au calme le jeu
s'est essayée c'est c'est un peu
stupéfiant que les forces
militaire libanaise sont des gens les
ports et les citoyens de même son port
le problème c'est que les pouvoirs
politiques libanais met les peuples dans
une état dans un état de guerre
tant que la tandis que le business
politique c'est-à-dire toute cette
classe qui ont gouverné depuis détester
continue dans le même pas cours pas de
contrôle et toutes les solutions sont
caduques
y'a pas un balle roule d'assainissement
public c'est pour cela les gens à se
fermer sur la question est bien compris
les justement sur la question de
d'amnesty international en gros vous
vous reprochez entre guillemets à cette
ong de s'appesantir voilà sur finalement
la responsabilité de la france dans la
distribution d'armes au liban petto de
s'occuper entre guillemets des problèmes
profonds du du pays c'est ce que vous
êtes en train de de nous dire parce que
justement il ya quand même des
manifestants qui sont blessés avec des
armes vendues par la france en tout cas
selon amnesty international bien
évidemment
ça ne vous choque pas vous à titre
personnel en tout cas ça me choque en
premier ça me choque toute sorte de
violence tout acte de violence de toute
sorte et bien je vois que je ne leur
reproche rien il ya un meeting à
quiconque il ya un grand problème dans
le pays est actuellement il ya des
lianes des actes de violence de part et
d'autre le problème c'est que en tant
que catéchistes julie tic et dans les
droits de la personne moi je suis contre
tout acte de violence perpétré par
quiconque
les choses doivent être pacifiquement
pacifiquement résolues d'une façon
humaine civilisé cette façon aussi n'est
pas acceptable ni de pas ni d'autre on
veut pas des manifestants qui sont qui
vont au delà du système juridique c'est
contre la loi c'est-à-dire et de même on
veut pas les forces de sécurité qui
peuvent mener des actes de violences
avec des armes français ou au co2
provenant d'autres pays comprenait des
gens civils qui n'ont pas quelqu'un qui
sont des amis vous savez il ya c'est un
grand problème c'est le grand dilemme
c'est un grand dilemme c'est dommage que
le liban pays de liberté démocratie
c'était quasi cessé d'écouler du score
jusqu'au jusqu'au bout dans cet état et
on voit des des photos ou à des
événements on voit des discours des gens
le discours public c'est à dire qui est
vraiment ce qui nous choque si tu nous
choque
clairement aujourd'hui ces manifestants
vous dites il ne faut pas que non plus
hors du cadre juridique mais est-ce
qu'ils ont le choix vu la situation on a
parlé de ce triple problème à des poèmes
socio économique
à cela s'ajoutent les restrictions en
raison de la crise sanitaire quel est le
choix aujourd'hui pour la population
quelle marge de manoeuvre pour le mettre
mal compris moi je suis avec la
révolution
je suis avec les gens les manifestants
qui disent non à tout ce processus de
mézens politique qui a volé les
générations d'ibanez depuis trois 3 4
des 6 je suis avec mais il ya une petite
minorité entre les manifestants qui
utilisent des armes contre les forces de
sécurité et contre l'eire mais ça c'est
pas acceptable casas et c'est contre la
loi mais la manif des manifestations
doit continuer et pas tripoli dans tout
le liban
le système ne peut pas continuer de
cette façon si c'est un système
d'appauvrissement qui n'est plus
crédible ni devant son peuple ni devant
la la la communauté internationale c'est
pour cela les manifestants n'ont pas le
choix ils sont hors ils n'ont plus de
devoir vivre certains vraiment c'est une
haine pour le liban c'est une haine pour
le liban mais à vrai dire on veut pas on
veut pas aller jusqu au complot c'est à
dire jusqu'à jeudi jusque une le
déclenchement d'une nouvelle guerre
civile ou des troubles sécuritaires
de toutes sortes on n'a pas les moyens
on abat on n'a pas les nerfs on n'a pas
la qualité de faire des troubles
sécuritaires vous savez la qualité de
vie au liban n'est plus la même c'est
pour cela la dernière question antoine
sfeir qu'attendez-vous du du pouvoir
aujourd'hui
moi j'attends que tout ce que je
possédais nationale a dit tout ce que
les autres les organisations
internationales qu'ils à propos du liban
à propos de la situation à propos de
l'épisode qui ont des armes qui ne sont
pas acquis qui n'est pas acceptable
suivant le toit internationale donc je
suis juge tient à coeur car je suis
spécialiste dans ce domaine il faut
respecter les droits de la personne et
dans la dans l'expression de leurs
emails d et dans le service et leur
qualité de vie
c'est pour cela le pouvoir libanais doit
faire une enquête imminent afin de
donner une crédibilité à tout ce qui se
passe sur le plan politique et 7 unitel
sinon et je doute fort qu'elle que que
le pouvoir à ce souci je doute fort
la violence ne peut engendrer que la
violence et si le pouvoir pas apaisé les
gens par la violence ça peut pas aller
ça va engendrer beaucoup de troubles et
de soucis qui pouvons belle du lait
pendant r peut-être des moins des des
années si des solutions fermes ne sont
pas là merci beaucoup antoine sfeir
avocat à paris et beyrouth d'avoir été
avec nous pour vu de l'extérieur ce soir
et on le disait de nombreux libanais qui
se retrouvent sans aucun revenu depuis
l'imposition du confinement françois
tessier reach
à tripoli des manifestants tentent de
mettre le feu au siège du gouvernorat de
la région du nord du liban
une nouvelle soirée de manifestations
contre les restrictions sanitaires
émaillée d'affrontements avec les forces
de sécurité
jeudi dernier les autorités libanaises
ont décidé de prolonger jusqu'au 8
février
le confinement strict mis en place le 14
janvier un confinement qui s'accompagne
d'un couvre feu 24 heures sur 24 et
d'une fermeture des commerces uniquement
autorisée à livrer à domicile
pourtant lorsqu'on se rend dans l'un des
marchés de la ville de tripoli
nombreux sont les libanais bravant
quotidiennement les interdits une
question de survie pour les travailleurs
journaliers représentant près de la
moitié de la population active libanaise
car avec la terrible crise économique
qui touche le pays
restez à la maison est synonyme pour
beaucoup de familles ils nous ont ruiné
ils nous ont transformés en mendiants
on n'a plus les moyens de manger les
gens meurent les gens manche qu'il
trouve dans les poubelles
vous voulez acheter à manger et nourrir
vos enfants vous ne pouvez pas ils nous
ont détruit les tailles corrompu l'état
est une ordure l'état nous a rabaissés
au plus bas l'état autorisé des fêtes
pour le nouvel an et à gagner des
millions ils ont fait la fête
ils ont terminé puis nous on dit
coronavirus et ont fermé les magasins
nous n'avons rien à manger les autorités
libanaises assurent distribué 400 me
livre par mois soit environ 219 euros à
230 mille ménages défavorisés
un montant jugé insuffisant dans un pays
en proie à une inflation à trois
chiffres
de l'aveu même du ministre des affaires
sociales trois libanais sur cat aurait
désormais besoin d'une aide de l'état
dans un liban frappé depuis plus d'un an
par des restrictions sur les retraits
bancaires une dépréciation de sa monnaie
des licenciements massifs et des baisses
salariales
les retombées sociales du confinement
sont désastreuses d'après l'onu plus de
la moitié des libanais vivent
aujourd'hui sous le seuil de pauvreté et
près du quart dans l'extrême pauvreté
en tunisie le président de la république
ait said a reçu ce mardi un courrier
suspect selon les autorités de courrier
ouvert par un membre du cabinet du
président contenait une matière suspecte
et enquête a donc été ouverte pour
déterminer sa nature et sa provenance
les médias locaux ont évoqué la
possibilité d'un empoisonnement à la
ricine un agent biologique très toxiques
voire mortels mais personne forte
heureusement n'a été touché elle a
restons la tension reste palpable dans
le pays alors que le parlement tunisien
a approuvé ce mardi le remaniement du
gouvernement le chef du gouvernement il
m
mais city a présenté onze nouveaux
ministres hier de nouvelles
manifestations sont attendues sur le sol
tunisien les explications de notre
reporter sur place abbas m shelly malgré
un vote de confiance qui est arrivé très
tard dans la nuit au parlement avec 11
nouveaux députés qui composent
actuellement le gouvernement de vichy la
tension est toujours palpable à tunis et
sur l'ensemble du territoire
je vous rappelle que depuis le 14
janvier dernier premier jour du
confinement généralisée et anniversaire
du des 10 ans de la révolution
tunisienne des tensions éclatent et de
vives tensions entre jeunes et
manifestants surtout dans les quartiers
populaires des tensions qui ont amené à
plusieurs manifestations globale sur
l'ensemble du pays à l'appel de
plusieurs associations de la société
civile mais également à l'appel de
plusieurs syndicats
l'opposition politique elle écrit au
scandale elle reconnaît que le parti
islamiste ennahda a largement influencé
le choix d'essayer onze nouveaux
ministres choisis par le gouvernement
mais chichis les tensions restent
palpables de nouvelles manifestations
sont à prévoir
mais à la différence des quelques jours
qui sont passé aucun appel à manifester
sur les réseaux sociaux car la police
réprime toute appel à manifester
certaines personnes ont été arrêtées des
personnes qui ont appelé à manifester la
société civile a pointé du doigt ces
pratiques de la police se disant que
c'est une violation de la liberté
d'expression la liberté d'expression qui
a des seuls acquis depuis cette
révolution de jasmin il ya maintenant
dix ans la tension restait extrêmes sur
l'ensemble du pays d'autres
manifestations sont à prévoir alors
qu'au sein même du gouvernement 2
belle tensions ont éclaté entre
l'opposition et le parti majoritaire à
savoir le parti ennahdha et 11 de
ministres qui ont été validées par
l'assemblée nationale
onze ministres qui n'ont pas eu tous
l'aval du président de la république
right side qui a reconnu que certains
ministres étaient corrompus n'avait pas
donné l aval pour tous ces ministres
voilà ce que l'on peut dire
actuellement en tunisie alors que la
tension reste assez palpable sur tunis
la capitale et sur l'ensemble du
territoire
un remaniement gouvernemental menée par
le premier ministre a aussi contesté par
une large partie de la rue ainsi que par
le président du pays
quentin mauclair un remaniement qui
passe mal en tunisie alors que le
parlement a accordé sa confiance au
nouveau gouvernement le président de la
république tunisienne et kaïs sayyed a
déjà émis de vives critiques contre
l'équipe choisie en marge des tensions
au sommet de l'état des centaines de
manifestants se sont réunis ce mardi
près du parlement
en cause la répression policière contre
le mouvement de contestation sociale qui
a commencé à la mi janvier
je suis ici pour réclamer des libertés
les droits et la justice
je suis venu aujourd'hui pour que tout
le monde soit ensemble
je suis venu ici aujourd'hui parce qu'en
tant que jeune cet état a dépensé pour
m'éduquer comme mes parents l'ont fait
pour que je puisse réclamer mes droits
la pandémie nous la combattons ensemble
mais pas au détriment d'autres problèmes
au lendemain du 10e anniversaire de la
révolution un mouvement de contestation
s'est propagée dans plusieurs villes du
pays
les tunisiens descendent dans les rues
depuis plus de dix jours pour protester
contre la crise économique sociale et
politique que traverse le pays
ces tensions se sont accentuées avec la
crise sanitaire ou politicien je leur
dis une chose si vous avez quelque chose
à dire au peuple ne le dit pas avec les
forces de l'ordre ne le dit pas avec
l'aide du ministère de l'intérieur
sortait voir le peuple et fait lui face
en dix ans il n'y a aucune stratégie ni
perspectives pour l'avenir ni même
l'espoir que les choses changent
au contraire chaque année l'espoir
diminue aujourd'hui en 2021 a
pratiquement tous les jeunes sont
désespérés tous les jeunes rêvent de
deux choses soit il ému
gris clandestinement soit il s'immole
des émeutes nocturnes entre manifestants
et forces de l'ordre ont éclaté lors des
premiers jours de contestation face à la
colère des jeunes tunisiens
le premier ministre hicham et chichi a
tenté de calmer les esprits ce mardi le
chef du gouvernement a assuré qu'il
serait à l'écouté des jeunes
protestataires
l enquête se poursuit en russie après
des manifestations illégales en soutien
alexeï navalni le week-end dernier la
correspondance depuis moscou d'antoine
cléroux une vingtaine de perquisitions
en lien avec les événements du 23
janvier ont été menées pour violation
des normes sanitaires en effet les
manifestations de samedi dernier était
interdite par les autorités en raison
des mesures de lutte contre la pandémie
de coronavirus qui empêche les
rassemblements en plus des perquisitions
plusieurs membres de l'entourage de
l'opposant russe ont été arrêtés comme
son frère oleg la vanille ou encore ses
collaborateurs lioubov sobol et leonid
volkov
ce dernier d'ailleurs accusé d'avoir
lancé des appels à manifester à
destination des mineurs a tranché niveau
commence le comité d' enquête de la
fédération de russie a engagé des
poursuites pénales contre volkov en
vertu de l'article du code pénal qui
établit la responsabilité pour
incitation de mineurs via les réseaux
d'information et de télécommunication à
commettre des actes illégaux
volkov savait pertinemment que les
autorités compétentes n'avait pas
autorisé l'organisation des
manifestations en raison de la situation
sanitaire et épidémiologique complexe
malgré cela ce 21 janvier il a publié
sur youtube des appels adressés aux
mineurs a participé le 23 janvier aux
manifestations non autorisée à moscou et
dans d'autres villes de russie dans des
conditions leur sécurité n'était pas
assurée curieux comme visa pas si c'est
de façon générale les autorités ne
voient pas d'un très bon oeil le rôle
des réseaux sociaux dans l'organisation
d'événements interdit en l'occurrence
les manifestations en question le
service fédéral de supervision des
communications des technologies de
l'information et des médias de masse a
fait un grand travail dans ce sens il a
exhorté divers réseaux sociaux à ne pas
devenir des plateformes pour ses appels
et le parquet réagit également à cela
c'est compréhensible en tant qu'etat à
nous aimerions qu'ils ne deviennent pas
des plateformes qui servent à annoncer
de telles actions illégales
pendant ce temps la procédure en appel
excellent navali concernant l'extension
de sa détention à une durée de 30 jours
a été rejetée opposants russes qui
durant son audience s'est plaint de
n'avoir pu depuis son arrestation le 17
janvier consulter ses avocats en privé
reste maintenant à observer si les
soutiens dans l'excès et la vanille se
mobiliseront une fois de plus ce week
end alors que le 2 février un tribunal
de moscou va statuer sur la violation de
sa période probatoire motifs de son
arrestation à son arrivée à moscou
un juge va donc décider si sa
condamnation avec sursis se transformera
ou non en peine de prison ferme
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous reviendrons sur la crise du
coronavirus en europe notamment et
particulièrement aux pays bas où l'idée
du couvre feu semble entrer dans les
consciences et le pays retrouve son
calme
en france les décisions de l'exécutif se
font attendre désespérément re
confinement ou pas le suspense reste
entier ont fait le point sur
l'intervention du ministre de la santé
[Musique]
l'hypothèse de rendre obligatoire le
vaccin pose problème ce qui est en cause
c'est votre liberté
mais ce qui est en cause aussi c'est la
liberté des autres
et entre la liberté individuelle et la
liberté collective il faut choisir la la
la gouvernance c'est compliqué la
pandémie après les gilets jaunes le
terrorisme islamique ça fait quand même
beaucoup tout ça
le fondement de la politique c'est la
rumeur ont réagi à des rumeurs et plus
qu'à des réalités ça comme conséquence
que la politique est devenue un métier
du spectacle
la loi est un objet de communication
politique trop de lois tuent la loi d'
et les lois inutiles tu les beaunois
et
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même il
ya à peu près un enfant sur deux en
france qui est soit victime soit hauteur
de cyber violent sur internet un contenu
haineux de quelqu'un qui dit à une
fillette de 8 ans va te suicider ça ça
doit être retirée immédiatement il n'ya
aucun débat à avoir sur son retrait là
parce que ça ça fait des suicides la loi
le condamne déjà c'est déjà interdit de
faire ça bien sûr mais c'est juste que
le légat fall de l'apli pas la justice
est lente et c'est très problématique
qui va prendre ce rôle de régulateur la
loi peut aider l'éducation peut aider
selon les différentes catégories
d'attaquants et d'attaquer une erreur de
la loi via ça a été de tout mettre dans
le même panier sous le sous le nom aide
en ligne quel rôle pour les réseaux
sociaux on a vu les big for donc les
gaffes à s'organiser pour annuler
quelqu'un sur internet ce quelqu'un
c'était donald trump quand il s'agit
d'un bannissement si général pour moi ce
n'est pas aux gaffes à et aux réseaux
sociaux à dublin des entreprises privées
de prendre cette décision mais ça doit
être à la justice de prendre cette
décision
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous cet
écho positif n'a jamais été obligé de
dire la vérité
les ide et courageuse des mots qui
comptent la haine françois vient de
l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on a une gauche extrêmement
intéressant
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview il n'y a pas
une façon plus pauvres de défendre un
système que de dire qu'il est moins pire
que notre peuple
sap est une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative au sort du ppri il
est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu livrant une forme c'est quand même
des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas l'oublié
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est on dirait qu'il ya quand
même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
nora lakehal a été la première femme à
intégrer le groupe
islamisme radical de la saur c'est
l'élite des renseignements généraux de
la police française et c'était après les
attentats du 11 septembre
et quand on vient vous voir et qu'on
vous dit écoutez vous avez de la
première femme qui allait rentrer dans
ce service
vous ne pouvez absolument pas refusé
votre mission première est celle de
traquer ces terroristes ce prêcheur
salafistes il vous a des tranchées pour
reprendre un code policiers il vous a
reconnu que c'est fini pour moi est ce
que je sors mon arme
tout est passé dans ma tête est ce que
vous avez appris de ces profils
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont chercher
d'ailleurs dans la religion le profil
vient toujours de la misère sociale
quand on écoute comme ça dit malheur
mais quel est le rapport avec la
radiation mais c'est la radicalisation
il faut que nous reprenions la place
dans le cerveau des enfants et de la
jeunesse
[Musique]
ce qu'on attend un peu de vous c'est les
idées pour en sortir est votre jugement
notamment de la façon dont cette crise
est gérée ce qui a été montré au cours
de la gestion de cette crise c'est le
déficit d'anticipation pour moi la
politique c'est d'abord d'être efficace
dès qu'il ya un manque de cohérence
il ya il ya un manque de fiabilité il ya
un manque de confiance faut vite
retrouver la confiance vous considérer
aujourd'hui que que la france a été plus
mauvaise que beaucoup de nos payes et
étrangers nous sommes le pays qui a
inventé les vaccins avec pasteur dont la
réactivité française n'a pas été à la
hauteur de notre réputation tout le
monde a vu que dès le mois de juillet
les chinois vacciner pourquoi est-ce
qu'on a attendu si longtemps
la question est de savoir comment est-ce
qu'on va retrouver un équilibre en
faisant en sorte que les épreuves que
nous subissons actuellement deviennent
des forces et non pas des handicaps
durable
[Musique]
alors que l'économie mondiale à plonger
les bourses elles tiennent le coup un
rebond forcément en mars après la chute
importante est tout à fait naturel mais
la hausse qui a poursuivi n'est
absolument pas en relation avec
l'économie aujourd'hui il faut tenir les
marchés à tout prix et pour les tenir
bien vous déversez des liquidités vous
avez une banque centrale qui fixe les
prix on est dans un régime de prix
administre convoi finalement une bourse
qui continue de progresser malgré les
mauvaises nouvelles
il va maintenant falloir surtout
retrouver cette corrélation entre
l'économie et les marchés financent ces
marchés financiers sont boostés boosté à
la dette boosté à l'argent qui est
imprimé par la banque centrale est la
principale conséquence c'est la
disparition de la valeur de la monnaie
[Musique]
il ya à peu près un enfant sur deux en
france qui est soit victime soit hauteur
de cyber violence sur internet un
contenu haineux de quelqu'un qui dit à
une fillette de 8 ans on va te suicider
ça ça doit être retirée immédiatement il
n'ya aucun débat à avoir sur ce retrait
là parce que ça ça fait des suicides la
loi le condamne déjà c'est déjà interdit
de faire ça bien sûr mais c'est juste
que les gaffes à ne l'appliquent pas la
justice est lente et c'est très
problématique qui doit prendre ce rôle
de régulateur la loi peut aider
l'éducation peut aider selon les
différentes catégories d'attaquants et
d'attaquer une erreur de la loi via ça a
été de tout mettre dans le même panier
sous le sous le nom et dans l'hymne quel
rôle pour les réseaux sociaux on a vu
les big for donc les gaffes à
s'organiser pour annuler quelqu'un sur
internet ce que quelqu'un s'était donald
trump quand il s'agit d'un bannissement
si général pour moi ce n'est pas aux
gaffes à et aux réseaux sociaux à douala
des entreprises privées de prendre cette
décision mais ça doit être à la justice
de prendre sa décision
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
c'est tjrs écho positif n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité
les ide et courageuse des mots qui
comptent la haine françois vient des
lignes aujourd'hui on a une gauche
extrêmement
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
bref bonsoir à tous merci de nous
rejoindre pour cette deuxième émission
tout de suite voici les titres de
l'actualité de ce jeudi 28 janvier
aux pays-bas la pression retombe après
plusieurs nuits de violences urbaines
une révolte dans plusieurs villes
déclenchée après l'instauration d'un
couvre-feu samedi dernier elle si le
calme est revenu des appels à de
nouvelles actions sont lancés pour ce
week end
le pays s'interroge sur les personnes
responsables de ces troubles que le
gouvernement qualifie lui de racaille et
de criminels les nouvelles mesures
attendues contre le kobe 19 feront
l'objet d'un débat et d'un vote à
l'assemblée et au sénat la semaine
prochaine alors que l'efficacité du
couvre-feu s'estompe selon olivier
ferrand qui parle d'épidémie dans
l'épidémie si l'on ne fait rien le porte
parole du gouvernement évoque lui
l'allongement des vacances de février
sancerre foutu quelles limites aux quoi
qu'il en coûte dépensé sans compter en
réponse à la crise sanitaire c'était le
credo des manuels macron aujourd'hui son
abandon n'est plus taboue certains
membres du gouvernement évoque même déjà
à deux reprises des réformes autrement
dit de nouveau tour de vis
alors l'austérité va-t-elle faire son
retour une fois la présidentielle de
2022 passé c'est le thème de l'édito
échos de jacques sapir
changement de cap dans la politique
américaine au moyen-orient les états
unis on trouve les portes washington
reviendra dans les corps du nucléaire
iranien cité on respecte ses engagements
l'administration des douanes suspense et
bandas maria des deux chasseurs f 35 aux
émirats arabes unis
le nouveau président qui profitent des
sondages favorables
une semaine après l'investiture
[Musique]
à
aux pays-bas depuis la flambée de
violence déclenchée après l'instauration
d'un couvre-feu samedi dernier la
situation semble revenue au calme ont
peut-être provisoirement car de nouveaux
appels à des actions ont été lancées
pour ce week end plus de précisons tout
de suite avec mon amour et laure bonsoir
roda vous êtes donc à rotterdam quelle
est l'atmosphère sur place quelles sont
les mesures prises par les autorités d
re landaise et bien écoutez
pour l'instant c'est plutôt calme même
s'il est difficile de dire si cela va
continuer puisque est les émeutes y
organisent leur rassemblement de manière
sporadique il est donc compliqué de
savoir où ils vont être à l'avant c'est
d'ailleurs peuvent éclater à tout moment
ici à rotterdam plusieurs magasins ont
été vandalisés voire incendié et après
les affrontements qu'il ya eu la semaine
dernière et ces derniers jours elle est
mère de plusieurs villes ont pris des
mesures d'urgence par exemple ici à
rotterdam on se trouve actuellement le
maire de la ville
ahmed aboutaleb a mis en place un décret
qui autorise la police à renforcer et à
multiplier les arrestations
il faut savoir que ces émeutiers bien il
s'organise tout d'abord dans un premier
temps sur elle et réseaux sociaux
et puis d'après les médias néerlandais
la plupart seraient de jeunes
adolescents certains seraient des ferait
partie de groupes d'extrême droite et
d'autres seraient à des corona
sceptiques
le gouvernement néerlandais a promis de
son côté de sévir et a dit je ne
s'inclinera pas devant ce qu'il a
qualifié de la racaille ou est des
criminels il faut dire que le pays n'est
pas forcément habitué à ces débordements
à ce genre d'affrontement d'ailleurs
nous avons pu parler à quelques
policiers qui nous confiait bien que
c'était la première fois qu'ils avaient
à gérer ce genre de situation et la
classe politique prend ce problème très
au sérieux
le premier ministre mark rutte a déclaré
qu'il s'agissait des pires émeutes en 40
ans de son côté le nothing le
nationaliste git wild horse a quant à
lui appelé l'armée à intervenir une
proposition et qui a été rejetée par le
premier ministre mark rutte
selon as le
maire de rotterdam plusieurs suspects
qui ont été arrêtés seront présentés dès
demain devant la justice
plusieurs centaines de personnes ont
déjà été arrêtées ces derniers jours
et si cette soirée elle semble plutôt
calme pour l'instant
des rassemblements sont organisés et
prévus samedi et dimanche
merci madame ou dès lors en direct donc
de rotterdam et il n'y a pas que le pays
les pays-bas pardon qui sont en proie à
des manifestations c'est le cas
également dans plusieurs pays d'europe
professionnels de la culture
restaurateurs qu'on semble citoyens
turcs d'europe de ce vent de révolte qui
semble se lever des explications en
images de clément barbey ce jeudi
l'organisation mondiale de la santé a
indiqué qu'il était trop tôt pour lâcher
du lest sur les restrictions en europe
en espagne plusieurs milliers de
personnes ont défilé dans la capitale
pour protester contre les mesures
imposées par le gouvernement afin de
contrer l'épidémie les autorités ont
notamment décidé de restreindre les
déplacements entre les régions pour
l'italie les restaurateurs sont
descendus dans la rue pour crier leur
mécontentement
certains ont même décidé d'ouvrir
clandestinement depuis de 14 janvier un
décret à deux vitesses autorise les
établissements situés en zone jaune à
ouvrir tandis que ceux situés dans les
régions classées en zone orange ne
peuvent servir les clients sur place
dans la capitale autrichienne des
milliers de personnes ont défilé la
plupart sans masque pour protester
contre les conséquences économiques de
la pandémie sur les banderoles certains
réclament le départ du chef du
gouvernement
le chancelier sebastian course en
bulgarie des centaines de restaurateurs
et patrons de discothèques ont défilé
dans plusieurs villes contre la
fermeture de leur établissement
il estime que la moyenne actuelle de 500
cas par jour dans le pays est suffisante
pour alléger les restrictions et les
restrictions qui n'emporte pas
l'adhésion de certaines population alors
que le virus lui se propage toujours
autant le nombre mondial de cas
officiellement recensés à dépasser les
100 millions un bilan qui risque fort de
s'alourdir avec à la présence des
variants bien plus contagieux le
britannique touche 70 pays le sud
africain 31
on compte désormais deux millions de
morts sur la planète en raison du
cabinda et cette question quelle est
l'origine de ce virus mortel comment
at-il été géré par la chine les experts
de l oms sont sortis de quarantaine à
roanne ils vont donc entamer leur
enquête sur les origines du nouveau
coronavirus plus d'un an après son
apparition dans cette ville du centre de
la chine françois xavier lambert c'est
la fin d'une quarantaine de deux
semaines enfermé dans un hôtel de one la
dizaine de membres de l' oms enfin pu
obtenir le feu vert des autorités
chinoises après être monté à bord d'un
bus spécialement affrété ils ont pris la
route pour commencer leurs
investigations selon le bilan officiel
chinois plus de 4600 personnes ont été
tuées par le virus dans le pays
dans un premier temps les experts locaux
avaient expliqué que l'épidémie était
apparu dans un marché de la ville où
étaient vendus des animaux sauvages mais
les médias d'état ont progressivement
écarté cette théorie pour une autre
le virus aurait pu être importées en
chine avec de la viande congelée dans le
reste du monde d'autres explications
sont apparus sans jamais aucune preuve
concrète notamment la possibilité d'un
accident au sein du laboratoire de
virologie de one
là où se récréer des coronavirus à des
fins de recherche
autant d'hypothèses démentie par la
chine alors que l'om s était accusé par
donald trump d'être aux ordres de pékin
une fermeté envers les autorités
chinoises reprise à son compte par la
nouvelle administration américaine
il est impératif que nous allions au
fond des choses quant à l'apparition de
la pandémie en chine
washington évaluera la crédibilité du
rapport d' enquête une fois qu'elle sera
terminée
la position des états unis a rapidement
suscité une réaction de pékin en
officiels chinois ainsi accusé
l'administration de joe biden de vouloir
politiser l'enquète de l' oms
nous rejetons les a priori négatifs et
les ingérences politiques dans le
travail des enquêteurs
de plus en plus d'études y compris de l'
oms montre que remonter à l'origine du
coc vite 19 est un processus qui va
continuer à s'étendre à plusieurs
régions et foyers épidémiques la durée
de l'anc est de l'om est ce n'est pas
connu elle se déroule alors que la chine
entrera le 11 février dans son long
congé du nouvel an lunaire le pays
tournera au ralenti pendant au moins une
semaine est la course au vaccin se
poursuivent 16h20 tech et moderna sont
actuellement disponibles dans l'union
européenne et ont permis de lancer les
campagnes de vaccination d'autres
devraient arriver dans le courant de
l'année 2021
on fait le point avec leïla ça ces
derniers jours tous les regards sont
tournés vers lui
astrazeneca doit rendre des comptes le
vaccin du groupe pharmaceutique qui
pourrait être le troisième être approuvé
au sein de l'union européenne a été
recommandée au moins de 65 ans
uniquement par la commission de
vaccination allemande
mais le laboratoire dément et affirme
qu'il est aussi efficace pour les
personnes de cette tranche d'âge lui a
commandé 300 millions de doses du vaccin
avec une option d'achat de 100 millions
supplémentaires
mais un autre problème existe toujours
astrazeneca annoncé une baisse de 60 %
des livraisons attendues
un retard qui serait due d'après la
firme a des soucis de rendement dans sa
chaîne de production européenne de son
côté bruxelles s'impatiente
l'europe a investi des milliards pour
développer les premiers vaccins et créer
un véritable come un mondial maintenant
les entreprises doivent tenir leurs
promesses
pour sa part faiza biotech promet plus
de 100 millions de doses pour le d'ici
fin 2021 après une première commande de
400 millions en france plus d'un million
de doses de ce vaccin ont été injectés
moderne à est encore loin derrière
seulement cinquante mille premières
doses ont été transférés sur le
territoire français premier né dans la
grande course au vaccin le spoutnik v
produit en russie et l'ue est encore
quasiment absents sur le vieux continent
une situation qui pourrait toutefois
évoluer si l' agence européenne de
médicaments venait à valider son dossier
vladimir poutine se montre confiant je
dirais que nous avons de grands projets
au cours de cette campagne de
vaccination contre la grippe
presque 70 millions de personnes se sont
fait vacciner comme anna popova
m'informer hier il s'agit de 68 millions
de personnes dans la lutte contre le
coronavirus nous devons atteindre plus
ou moins le même niveau
reste à savoir si les vaccins français
ont encore un rôle à jouer
l'union européenne a notamment pré
commandé 300 millions de doses à la
firme sanofi
malgré l'arrêt de son principal projet
l'institut pasteur à lui engagé ses
recherches sur deux autres candidats
vaccins la crise sanitaire en france
seule porte parole du gouvernement en
gabriel attal annonce ce soir l'objectif
de 2,5 millions de personnes vaccinées
fin février plus tôt dans la journée
pas de grandes annonces d'olivier
verrons lors de sa conférence de presse
varian et animations couvre-feu autant
de sujets abordés pour selon lui
expliquer les futures mesures mises en
place par le gouvernement
le couvre-feu qui n'est pas suffisamment
efficace selon le ministre de la santé
écoutez là où nous avons mis en place un
couvre-feu à 18h30 au tout début du mois
de janvier
il ya d'abord eu un effet réel de baisse
de la pression épidémique
puis une stabilisation dans le reste du
pays là où il n'y avait pas de
couvre-feu
tout début du mois de janvier l'épidémie
a été un peu plus forte ces dernières
semaines ce qui veut dire que
globalement le couvre-feu à 18h à une
efficacité probablement at il permis que
nous évitions de connaître la même vague
épidémique que nombre de nos voisins
mais à l'évidence cette efficacité
s'estompe et à l'évidence cela ne suffit
pas à faire reculer le virus est la
surprise générale les parlementaires de
la majorité ont voté la fin de la
mission d'information sur les crises du
coc vie de 19
elle avait pourtant permis de disséquer
la gestion de l'épidémie et
d'auditionner les acteurs de la crise
les élus d'opposition qui avait demandé
la poursuite de la mission dénonce une
trahison démocratique
adieu mission d'information
parlementaire sur la crise du colis 19
les députés de la majorité ont voté
mercredi pour la dissoudre
au grand dam des élus de l'opposition
revenons sur ce tour de passe-passe pour
ausculter la gestion très critiquée de
la crise du coc vide
une commission d' enquête comprenant des
députés de tous bords a été créée le 17
mars 2020 parmi elles agnès buzyn
ministre de la santé au début de la
crise ses prédécesseurs roselyne
bachelot marisol touraine
ainsi que jean castex olivier verront le
directeur de la santé jérôme salomon
mêmes l'inénarrable didier raoul tu un
premier rapport a été rendu en juin 2020
il notait que notre système de soins
avait tenu bon mais ils relevé des
faiblesses comme l'insuffisance des
stocks stratégiques d'équipements de
protection et notamment de masques la
dépendance à l'égard de l'extérieur pour
les produits indispensables
il s'avérait critique envers santé
publique france et les ars second temps
la mission s'est dotée des prérogatives
d'une commission denquête son rapport
rendu par le rapporteur républicain eric
ciotti début décembre 2020
s'avérer bien plus cinglant très précis
lourdeurs bureaucratiques et
administratives insuffisante
médicalisation des ehpad retard dans la
prise de conscience de la gravité de la
situation
manque structurel de personnel soignant
sent perdue dans le recours aux hôpitaux
privés
il n'est pas réglé le manque de
protection des médecins de ville
l'impréparation du dépistage de masse le
retard en matière de tests non jetez
plus plus de 200 pages de critique qui
nous replonge dans les affres de 2020
les députés ont donc demandé la
poursuite en mission d'information pour
continuer à accompagner la crise et
suivre la stratégie vaccinale mais les
députés de la majorité ont voté son art
et provoquant l'indignation des
parlementaires de l'opposition
damien abad président du groupe
républicain l'assemblée a évoqué un
naufrage démocratique vexiau ti le
rapporteur républicain de la mission
s'est plaint d'un coup de force
institutionnel macro et ses ministres
ont peur d'assumer publiquement leur
politique hasardeuse a dénoncé jean-luc
mélenchon on écoute eric coquerel député
insoumis révolté par l'arrêt des travaux
hélas la seule mission qui avait pour
rôle de quand même contrôlé et de
pouvoir réagir à la gestion de la crise
pas aujourd'hui et est éliminé s'indigne
dérive autoritaire de plus en plus
fortes à dire que
manifestement le chef de l'état supporte
pas que c'est les 66 millions de
citoyens français est un avis sur la
question il exprime c'est un peu le
symbole de monsieur macro qui
on est obligé de supporter le fait
qu'ils aient une assemblée mais ne tient
véritablement pas lui donner plus drôle
que ça du côté de la majorité christophe
castaner le chef de file des députés lrm
a rétorqué les commission denquête
émissions d'information sont temporaires
c'est la vie parlementaire julien borde
sic président en marge de la mission
d'information estime que d'autres
commissions peuvent se servir de la
suite de la crise certes et pourquoi pas
celle ci très au fait des tenants et
aboutissants pour assurer une continuité
en mars 2020 la mission devait examiner
la gestion et les conséquences de
l'épidémie de coronavirus qui est loin
d'être terminée alors pourquoi enterrer
cette mission et guillon qui regarder
dans le rétroviseur et identifier les
carences de la gestion étatique pour
améliorer la conduite des opérations
heureusement le cadavre bouge encore le
sénat embraye avec la création d'une
mission d'information destiné à évaluer
les effets des mesures prises en matière
de confinement ou de restriction de
liberté ou n'empêchera pas les sénateurs
de poser des diagnostics constructif
pour en parler nous sommes de décrocher
karoutchi sénateur précisément l ère des
hauts-de-seine c'est notre rubrique
l'invité ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir roger karoutchi merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur leur défense
vous voyez faire les gros yeux voilà
sourire sans doute ironiquement à ces
propos à votre réaction circulez ya rien
à voir
à du côté du gouvernement c'est clair
qu'on ne souhaite pas être très
contrôlés sur sa gestion de la crise
sanitaire
on sait depuis le début depuis les
errements sur les masques puis sur les
thèses puis dans la campagne vaccinale
le gouvernement n'a pas vraiment envie
que les parlementaires contrôle en
réalité sa gestion de la crise alors au
nom de l'unité nationale on voudrait
bien faire taire tout le monde alors à
l'assemblée nationale c'est possible
parce que la majorité aux ordres a fait
en sorte que la mission d'information
s'arrête au sénat où il ya déjà eu une
commission d' enquête qui a déposé un
rapport au mois de décembre la mission
d'information s'est mise en place cette
semaine
elle aura ses premières réunions dans
les semaines qui viennent jusqu'à l'été
j'en serais d'ailleurs rapporteur et je
n'ai pas l'intention d'obéir à une
quelconque diktat de qui que ce soit
nous allons faire notre travail de
parlementaire vérifier ce qui se fait
s'il ya des choses bien
faut pas que le gouvernement et si peur
que ça doit bien faire de temps en temps
des choses correctes
donc on dira que c'est bien s'il ya des
choses qui ne nous paraissent pas
correct auditionnera et je pense que les
ministres n'auront guère le choix à
parvenir être auditionné par le sénat
s'ils veulent pas être auditionné par
l'assemblée mais globalement je trouve
que un moment où on voit bien que
l'épidémie est loin d'être terminée
on voit bien au moment où la campagne
vaccinale patine et où il ya des
problèmes européens et français
on voit bien que si le gouvernement veut
un peu l'unité d'une opinion arriver à
peu près à faire retrouver la confiance
il faut qu'il accepte le dialogue il
faut qu'ils acceptent de parler il faut
qu'il accepte être contrôlée il faut
qu'il accepte que les parlementaires
pose des questions parce que dans le
fond les questions que nous posons sont
les questions que posent tous les
français qu'ils se posent quand est ce
qu'on va être confiné une troisième fois
est-ce que ça suffira est ce que comme
n'y aura pas assez de vent
que ça passait de vaccination d'ici
avril mais est ce qu'on ne risque pas
encore une quatrième un quatrième
confinement en avril ou en mai tom qu'on
ne sera pas arrivé à vacciner
suffisamment demande toutes ces
questions tous les français se posent
même s'ils sont dans la majorité
politique de monsieur vacants donc
autant qu'ils en débat au parlement
avec un rapport avec des échanges aux 46
66 millions de procureur nous reproche
un petit peu emmanuel macron quand même
type led le droit à l'erreur
vous le sentez un petit peu embarrassé
justement par ces critiques le président
de la république
si on en croit certaines réactions qu'il
a eue y compris par rapport à ses
ministres ou par rapport à certain
retard
je pense qu'il est assez embarrassé qui
se rend compte que cette crise sanitaire
est plus dur que le gouvernement ne le
prévoyaient que d'ailleurs la majorité
des experts ne prévient il faut pas non
plus jeter de pierres et uniquement là
dessus mais ce qui est clair c'est que
le gouvernement ne passera pas et le
prise en mains publiques ne passera pas
l'ensemble de cette crise sanitaire qui
va encore durer des mois sans avoir à
s'expliquer et c'est normal c'est le
gouvernement qui par définition elles
toi exécutive c'est lui qui prend les
décisions
il faut bien qu'il en rende compte c'est
ça le principal problème en supprimant
la mission d'information à l'assemblée
on a le sentiment que le gouvernement
voudrait pouvoir prendre des décisions
sans en rendre compte
mais ça ça n'existe pas nous sommes dans
une démocratie en république
le gouvernement n'est pas tout puissant
le président non plus il a des îles à
rendre des explications sur ce qu'il
fait sur ce que le gouvernement fait et
c'est normal c'est la vie des pratiques
les députés disent en fait ce travail
était tout simplement terminer cette
mission est terminée ils ne disent pas
qu'il ne voulait pas répondre aux
questions il estime tout simplement
qu'ils y ont répondu mais voilà qu'ils
ont donné les réponses est ce que pour
vous est ce que cette mission était
réellement terminée ce qu'il ya encore
des questions auxquelles vous n'avez pas
de réponse aujourd'hui je me permettrai
de vous répondre simplement par une
autre question est ce que la crise
sanitaire est terminée est-ce que nous
sommes sortis de la crise sanitaire on
voit bien nous avons au sénat comme à
l'assemblée fait les rapports des
commissions d enquête début des saints
donc on était encore loin des débuts de
la campagne vaccinale
on n'imaginait pas un troisième le
confinement on n'imaginait pas que la
crise économique sociale sociétale
allait être encore plus profonde et
devoir durer des mois
par conséquent très logiquement au sénat
on a dit la commission denquête a déposé
son rapport en décembre mais la crise
sanitaire et ses conséquences se
poursuivre
il est normal que le parlement puisse
avoir des explications des échanges et
qu'il y ait une mission d'information
il s'agit pas de créer des missions pour
condamner uniquement critiquer on
cherche à avoir des explications à
contrôler l'action qui est menée et
pardon mais le rôle du parlement c'est
le contrôler l'action du gouvernement
c'est dans la constitution
et je m'étonne qu'à l'assemblée on se
dessaisisse de ce pouvoir parce que ça
ne correspond pas du tout à l'esprit de
la vème république
on entendait pascal canfin l'autre jour
se plaindre de ne pas pouvoir obtenir
les contrats passés entre la commission
européenne et les laboratoires qui
fabriquent les vaccins ce que c'est un
axe par exemple sur lequel vous allez
vous essayer de travailler les sénateurs
pour avoir plus de transparence sur ces
commandes qui interroge beaucoup il faut
bien le dire
alors forcément nous on va beaucoup
s'intéresser à la vie franco-français si
je puis dire par rapport à la crise
mais c'est vrai que dans les
explications dans les discussions qui
auront lieu
c'est sûr que les ratés de la campagne
vaccinale qui ne sont pas que du fait de
l'état france a et b qui sont aussi du
fait peut-être de fautes d'erreurs dans
les liens en
l'union européenne et les laboratoires
aussi interroger le comportement des
laboratoires parce que pourquoi et
avait-il pris des engagements pourquoi
ces engagements ne sont pas tenus ou en
tout cas seulement partiellement
forcément c'est une question qui va se
poser et qui va se poser d'ailleurs au
delà de la mission d'information parce
que pardon mais même si l assemblée
nationale il ya plus de missions
d'information là dessus vous pensez aux
questions d'actualité
ces questions là les groupes
d'opposition vont pas déposer
naturellement que oui c'est pour ça que
je trouve assez ridicule de refuser de
maintenir la mission d'information à
l'assemblée parce que de toute manière
les questions vont être posées
de toute manière le gouvernement devra
s'expliquer et par conséquent il eût
mieux valu que ce soit dans un travail
coordonné concerter avec des missions
vraiment fait pour ça ce cover hausse et
sans esprit de polémique pour la
polémique même si le sénat est à
majorité de droite et du centre on sait
ce qui est l'unité nationale on sait ce
qu'est la nécessité de trouver des
solutions pour nos concitoyens
donc on va faire ça dans un esprit
constructif mais en voulant des
explications en voulant qu'on nous dise
clairement les choses de la transparence
c'est tout gouvernement qui en période
de crise joue la transparence ni perte à
voilà c'est la seule chose que je peux
dire au premier vide et franchement être
trouvé la parade pour éviter quelques
critiques puisqu'il va vous associez les
parlementaires à l'assemblée nationale
et le sénat la semaine prochaine puisque
vous et lettres invités à voter
il y aura un débat et un vote après les
nouvelles mesures qu'on attend tous avec
beaucoup d'impatience
c'est une manière peut-être aussi de
vous responsabiliser de ne plus endosser
toutes les responsabilités de ce genre
d'humour de décision alors pardon mais
il ya des subtilités dans la
constitution de ce côté là par exemple
on dit que de réalité pas par exemple au
sénat mardi
très bien sauf que apparemment je n'en
sais rien je peux plus influent que ça
on nous dit que le président la
république pourrait s'exprimer dès
dimanche ou lundi
c'est à dire qu'en réalité on va nous
faire débattre une fois les décisions
annoncées par le président de la
république à l'ensemble des français
donc c'est le franchement histoire de
dire qu'on fait quelque chose au
parlement deuxième élément pardon c'est
une subtilité mais le débat aura lieu en
fonction de l'article 50-1 de la
constitution et le vote qui suit n'est
qu'indicatif c'est à dire que quand fait
l'assemblée où le sénat
votre site c'est en réalité un débat
indicatif seul sera d'autant plus si le
président la république s'exprime avant
pour donner les vraies décisions parce
que ça voudra dire enfin des bas mais
sur les annonces faites par le président
et non pas sur qu'est ce qu'il faudrait
faire
ce qu'on demande d'ailleurs depuis des
mois et des mois où on demande
régulièrement au gouvernement mais
pourquoi ne n'arrive-t-on pas avoir un
débat parlementaire sur des solutions ou
des propositions par rapport à la crise
l'opposition d'être dans l'opposition ça
ne rend pas aveugle aux difficultés au
drame de beaucoup de français et tout le
monde souhaite sortir de la crise
sanitaire
et donc après tout on peut avoir des
idées je vois pas en quoi ce serait
aberrant qui est un vrai des parfums en
l'occurrence ce sera un débat post
décision présidentielle et qui ne sera
qu indique et x merci beaucoup aux
écarts aussi je rappelle que vous êtes
sénateur des hauts-de-seine merci
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france dans quelques instants rester
avec nous nous parlerons de la politique
du quoi qu'il en coûte avec notre
économiste jacques sapir puis aux etats
unis une semaine après son investiture
joe biden bénéficient
sondage favorable et peut compter sur le
soutien d'une majorité d'américains pour
l'instant
[Musique]
ce qu'on attend un peu de vous c'est des
idées pour en sortir est votre jugement
notamment de la façon dont cette crise
est gérée ce qui a été montré au cours
de la gestion de cette crise c'est le
déficit d'anticipation pour moi la
politique c'est d'abord d'être efficace
dès qu'il ya un manque de cohérence
il ya il ya un manque de fiabilité il ya
un manque de confiance faut vite
retrouver la confiance vous considérer
aujourd'hui que que la france a été plus
mauvaise que beaucoup de nos payes et
étrangers pour le pays qui a inventé les
vaccins avec pasteur dont la réactivité
française n'a pas été à la hauteur de
notre réputation tout le monde a vu que
dès le mois de juillet les chinois
vacciner pourquoi est-ce qu'on a attendu
si longtemps
la question est de savoir comment est-ce
qu'on va retrouver un équilibre en
faisant en sorte que les épreuves que
nous subissons actuellement deviennent
des forces et non pas des handicaps
durable
[Musique]
alors que l'économie mondiale à plonger
les bourses elles elles tiennent le coup
un rebond forcément en mars après la
chute importante est tout à fait naturel
mais la hausse qui a poursuivi n'est
absolument pas en relation avec
l'économie aujourd'hui il faut tenir les
marchés à tout prix et pour les tenir
bien vous déversez des liquidités vous
avez une banque centrale qui fixe les
prix on est dans un régime de prix
administrés
on voit finalement une bourse qui
continue de progresser malgré les
mauvaises nouvelles
il va maintenant falloir surtout
retrouver cette corrélation entre
l'économie et les marchés financiers
marchés financiers sont boostés boosté à
la dette boosté à l'argent qui est
imprimé par la banque centrale est la
principale conséquence c'est la
disparition de la valeur de la monnaie
le crime est tellement épouvantable que
je pense qu'une partie de l'église mais
comme une partie de la société ne veut
pas le voir de 1950 à aujourd'hui le
travail de la commission a permis
d'identifier trois mille victimes 1500
agresseurs ces chiffres sont forcément
présente sa de la réalité puisque des
victimes sont décédées des victimes ne
peuvent pas parler peut-être ne
parleront jamais ça montre cette
tragédie qui lie à un système au tour
c'est-à-dire comment des agresseurs
ont-ils pu agresser 10/20 parfois trente
ans nous sommes loin du bout du chemin à
vous savez des institutions se réforme
lentement l'église peut être encore plus
lentement je ne sais pas mais en tout
cas je pense que la prise de conscience
est fait de tels scandales de tels
drames de telles tragédies dans la vie
oblige à la vérité
comment vous jugez maintenant la façon
dont on a géré la crise parce que c'est
arrivé cette histoire personne ne
prenait pas au sérieux nos pieds il ya
beaucoup de gens qui ont compris après
les choses en main mais c'est presque
inévitable que l'on met tout le monde
dans le même panier et à dire que la
boîte de nuit le bistrot de quartier
à quelles conditions pires gagna allons
nous pouvoir ré ouvrir les restos c'est
pas les clés mon jeu je produis je
travaille je sais c'est de faire au
mieux c'est aussi tout un questionnement
sur la société sur le rapport à la
solidarité et le commerce
c'est le commerce et le sait le lien
entre donc dans le monde
est ce que vous vous allez vous faire
vacciner vous trois fois ci il faut un
évidemment
[Musique]
et
21h38 les bienvenus en direct sur rt
france si vous nous rejoignez à quelle
limite aux quoi qu'il en coûte dépensé
sans compter en réponse à la crise
sanitaire c'était le credo emmanuel
macron aujourd'hui son abandon et puis
vraiment à bout certains membres du
gouvernement l'évoquent alors que
d'autres non ce même déjà une reprise
des réformes autrement dit de nouveau
tour de vis l'austérité alors va-t-elle
faire son retour une fois la
présidentielle de 2000 22 pc on en parle
tout de suite avec l'économiste jacques
sapir
[Musique]
bonsoir jacquat bienvenus bonsoir
stéphanie alors jacques alors qu'on est
loin d'être sorti de l'épidémie
malheureusement pourquoi certains
évoque-t-il la fin du quoi qu'il en
coûte
effectivement le moment n'était pas très
bien choisi mais c'est vrai il ya de
plus en plus de voix qui commencent à
évoquer la fin de ce quoi qu'il en coûte
alors assez clair l'économie française
ne peut pas rester indéfiniment sous
tente à oxygène
mais est ce que ça veut dire que dès que
la crise sanitaire sera terminé on va en
revenir à des politiques d'austérité est
ce que ces politiques d'austérité sont
elles mêmes nécessaire c'est en réalité
un débat qui sera extrêmement important
je pense d'ici à l'élection
présidentielle de 2000 22
alors commençons par le commencement
peut-on dire aujourd'hui à partir de
quel moment les aides ne seront plus
nécessaires
alors c'est fini d'une certaine manière
on peut dire que au minimum
il faudra attendre à la fin de l'été
2021 en même temps il est clair que pour
que l'on arrive à une situation de fin
de l'épidémie il faudrait que je
contrôle mon tour des deux tiers des
français soient vaccinés ça nous fait
entre 40 et 45 millions dont 80 à 85
millions de 12
on voit bien compte tenu des difficultés
qu'ont aujourd'hui les laboratoires pour
fournir un des doses que c'est pas gagné
et par ailleurs quand on voit le côté un
petit peu chaotique de la stratégie
vaccinale du gouvernement c'est pas non
plus gagner de ce point de vue là donc
il est quand même plus probable que la
fin de la crise sanitaire
ça sera plutôt l'automne voir l'hiver
2021 2022
maintenant il faut savoir aussi qu'il ya
un certain nombre de gens et en
particulier il ya certains ministres
comme le ministre des comptes publics
monsieur olivier dussopt qui piaffent
d'impatience de proclamer justement la
fin de ce quoi qu'il en coûte
alors que d'autres ministres comme
madame elisabeth borne à la ministre du
travail
j'ai dit à l'ats vient réaffirmer que
ces aides seraient maintenus tout le
temps nécessaire de la crise sanitaire
alors la question s'est elle sont elles
nécessaires
ah oui elles sont plus que nécessaires
elles sont absolument indispensables si
vous voulez sans ces aides
on aurait un chômage qui aurait explosé
on aurait eu des faillites qui aurait
été absolument dévastatrice donc on voit
bien que ces aides
elles sont tout à fait nécessaire si on
veut contrôler les conséquences
économiques de cette crise sanitaire
maintenant d'un autre côté il faut aussi
comprendre que ces aides
c'est comme de la morphine alors de la
morphine oui on en donne à tous les
grands blessés
si vous voulez à l'hôpital c'est pas
parce que certains l'utilisent comme une
drogue ne qu'on ne doit pas l'utiliser
on le sait très bien
sauf que quand on arrêtera cette
morphine et quand la douleur et la
douleur économique reviendra eh bien on
va bien voir à ce moment là que
l'économie française va rentrer un petit
peu dans le dur de la crise économique
et donc là si vous voulez ce que l'on a
vu l'année dernière c'est que en 2020 on
a eu moins de faillites qu'on en avait
eu en 2019
devant les tribunaux
m et bien là on verra au contraire une
vague de faillites tout à fait
considérable se produire en france
oui mais jacques c z elle coûte cher à
l'état n'est ce pas oui ah oui oui tout
à fait tout à fait elle coûte cher
si vous voulez on sait déjà que en 2020
ça a provoqué grosso modo un
accroissement de 16 points du ratio
dette sur pib
on était en dessous juste en dessous de
100 % on est actuellement autour de 115
116 %
on sait aussi que avec le si vous voulez
les la perspective d'un nouveau
confinement
ça va encore coûter plus cher vous savez
le le confinement tel qu'il est organisé
maintenant massa devrait coûter au
gouvernement fait écouter à l'état
autour de 20 milliards par mois donc si
on se confine pour six semaines 30
milliards autrement dit en 2021
on sera plutôt vers 120 % de dette sur
le pipe c'est vraiment tout à fait
considérable alors jacquin comment
va-t-on financer évidemment sa dette
tout le monde se pose la question alors
pour l'instant il faut bien comprendre
que c'est la banque centrale européenne
à la bce et qui fait le travail
elle a très récemment dans une de ces
réunions
elle a décidé de prolonger son fameux
programme spécifique par rapport la
crise sanitaire ce qu'on appelle le ppp
ou aux pandémies émancipé chasing
programme
elle a décidé de le prolonger jusqu'en
mai 2022
elle a décidé aussi de le porter jusqu'à
1850 milliards d'euros donc il n'y a pas
de raison de s'inquiéter
maintenant il faut dire deux choses la
première c'est que là elle est un petit
peu seul à faire le travail parce qu'on
voit bien que la commission et l'union
européenne 1 n'arrivent pas à suivre le
fameux plan de relance dont on avait
beaucoup parlé cet été eh bien on avait
d'abord commencé à dire ça serait pour
le printemps 2000 21 puis pour l'été
2021 aujourd'hui on voit qu'il se
produira 10 ans et il rentrera en
fonction plutôt vers la fin 2021 voir le
début de 2022 ça c'est un premier point
et puis il ya quand même un deuxième
point c'est que un moment donné au delà
de dôme et 2022
on voit bien que les aides vont
s'arrêter et d'une certaine manière on
sera replacé devant cette question du
financement en 2023 après l'élection
présidentielle parce que si vous voulez
si je peux la me permettre un pronostic
il est évident que la banque centrale
européenne ne fera rien pour que les
difficultés puissent se matérialiser
avant l'élection présidentielle de 2000
22 alors pourtant jacques il semble bien
que le fonds monétaire international
voudront vous parliez appels à
l'austérité
dès maintenant alors c'est un petit peu
plus compliqué mais c'est vrai que si
vous voulez alors le fonds monétaire
international vient de remettre un
rapport sur la situation de la france un
rapport régulier et ils le font à peu
près tous les tous les 18 mois
donc ça ce n'est pas nouveau et dans ce
rapport il ya deux choses
il ya d'abord un jugement qui est porté
sur la situation actuelle et ce jugement
il est plutôt élogieux pour le
gouvernement il appelle même d'une
certaine manière le gouvernement à aller
plus loin dans les airs
là où ça pose problème c'est que ce même
rapport dit que quand la crise sera
terminée autres ni quand on ne sera plus
en situation d'urgence sanitaire
alors là il faudra faire des économies
et on voit là immédiatement que les
solutions proposées par le fonds
monétaire international va elles m'ont
complètement d'originalité qu'est ce
qu'ils demandent à il demande à ce que
il y a un programme d'économies sur les
dépenses
il demande aussi que l'on accélère
encore plus la financiarisation de
l'économie française autrement dit c'est
tout simplement un programme très
traditionnel d'austérité que le fonds
monétaire prévoit pour l'après état
d'urgence sanitaire
alors est-ce que cela ne pose pas un
gros problème l'économie française sera
t-elle
on est à subir une cure d'austérité
effectivement ça c'est un problème
fait évident parce que si vous voulez le
choc que nous avons subi que l'économie
française a subi là il faudra attendre
très certainement 2024 voire 2025 pour
qu'il soit d'une certaine manière
surmonter et dans ce rapport il ya une
phrase qui est tout à fait intéressante
c'est une fois la reprise solidement
assise un effort de consolidation basé
sur les dépenses sera nécessaire pour
placer la dette élevée de la france sur
une trajectoire descendante
autrement dit tout se passe comme si le
fonds monétaire international ne tenait
absolument pas compte du caractère très
exceptionnel de la dette liés à
l'épidémie il y ait à la copie 19 et on
voit bien que ce qui va se jouer là
c'est justement le retour à des
politiques d'austérité des politiques
d'austérité qui et c'est tout à fait
évident ne peuvent que provoquer une
phase de stagnation assez longue de
l'économie française alors qu'il
faudrait au contraire maintenir les
dépenses a bien entendu pas les mêmes
dépenses si vous voulez il n'est pas du
tout question de maintenir les aides
une fois que l'économie sera rouverte il
faudra d'autres aides à d'autres
secteurs afin de permettre justement à
ce que l'économie française revienne le
plus rapidement possible sur une
trajectoire de forte croissance
alors pour conclure jacques à quoi
peut-on s'attendre après la crise
sanitaire ducobu de 19 mais en fait on
est devant un deux possibilités soit
nous suivons la voie que nous propose
que ce soit le fonds monétaire
international que ce soit aussi l'union
européenne parce qu'il faut pas oublier
que l'union européenne
elle fait régulièrement des rappels qui
pousse le gouvernement en direction de
l'austérité en direction des fameuses
réformes structurelles et si on rentre
dans cette logique là et bien c'est très
clair l'économie française connaîtra une
période de longue stagnation ou période
longue stagnation qui est d'ailleurs un
petit peu l'avenir qui est promis à
l'union européenne
parce que au niveau international on
voit bien que c'est plutôt vers cette
dans cette direction si vous voulez que
va s'engager
l'union européenne ou alors on fait
autre chose on défend nos entreprises on
défend l'emploi
on cherche à créer justement de
nouvelles entreprises tout cela
demandera de l'argent ça demandera aussi
c'est un point extrêmement important que
l'on récupère notre souveraineté
économique
ça va être la souveraineté économique ce
n'est pas seulement de dire que des
prédateurs étrangers n'ont pas le droit
de venir s'attaquer à un fleuron de la
distribution française carrefour pour ne
pas le nommer
c'est aussi dire que ce dont on a besoin
pour sortir de cette crise c'est de tous
les instruments de la souveraineté
économique et quand je dis tout je pense
évidemment à l'instrument monétaire
merci jacques sapir vous entendre
évidemment comprend que ces choix seront
stratégiques pour sortir de cette crise
liée à la pandémie merci à vous et à la
semaine prochaine jacques aux états unis
état de grâce pour joe biden joe raedle
entame son mandat avec 54% d'opinions
favorables pour 30 % de mécontents selon
l'institut gallup dans une enquête
conduite entre le 21 et le 24 janvier
une autre enquête menée cette fois ci
par malines consul lui donne 56%
d'opinions favorables mais attention ces
bonnes opinions ne sont partagé que par
seuls 15% des républicains et 46% des
indépendants et le nouveau chef de la
diplomatie américaine anthony blinken a
détaillé lui la nouvelle stratégie à
venir de washington au moyen-orient
accord sur le nucléaire iranien conflit
au yémen ou encore normalisation des
relations entre certains pays arabes et
israël
joe biden qui examine réexamine même la
doctrine de son prédécesseur républicain
amaya soubelet la politique étrangère de
trump au moyen-orient remise en question
par l'administration maiden mercredi le
nouveau chef de la diplomatie anthony
blinken a évoqué les nombreux
changements à venir afin de rétablir des
relations multilatérales première
objectif
l'accord sur le nucléaire
bien de 2015 dont donald trump s'est
retiré le président biden a été très
clair en disant que si l'iran venait
respecter pleinement ses obligations au
titre de l'accord sur le nucléaire
iranien les états unis ferait de même et
nous utiliserions cela comme une
plateforme pour construire avec nous a
dit et partenaires ce que nous avons
appelé un accord plus long et plus fort
pour traiter un certain nombre d'autres
questions qui sont profondément
problématique dans les relations avec
l'iran mais nous en sommes encore loin
l'iran a cessé de respecter ses
engagements sur plusieurs fronts cela
prendra un certain temps pour eux de
respecter de nouveau leurs obligations
et il faudra aussi du temps pour que
nous puissions évaluer s'ils respectent
leurs obligations
toujours à propos du moyen orient le
bureau ovale a opté pour la suspension
d'une vente d'armes à l'arabie saoudite
et de chasseurs f-35 aux émirats arabes
unis les deux monarchies du golfe
soutiennent militairement le
gouvernement yéménite dans sa guerre
contre les rebelles houthi une procédure
de routine selon le département d'état
américain qui souhaite examiner les
objectifs stratégiques des armes
américaines utilisé dans ce conflit
un conflit qui a fait l'objet d'une
décision importante de la part de mike
pompéo juste avant son départ le 10
janvier dernier l'ancien chef de la
diplomatie des états unis a placé les
rebelles houthi au yémen sur la liste
noire des organisations terroristes
une mesure susceptible d'aggraver la
situation chaotique dans le pays
décision également réexaminer lundi par
la nouvelle administration et nous
réexaminons un certain nombre de mesures
qui ont été prises à la fin de la
dernière administration
nous voulons nous assurer que nous
comprenons dans chaque cas le fondement
des décisions qui ont été prises je me
concentre particulièrement sur la
question des sanctions contre les outils
il est d'une importance vitale même au
milieu de cette crise que nous fassions
tout notre possible pour apporter une
aide humanitaire au peuple du yémen qui
en a désespérément besoin
le président byden souhaite en revanche
garantir les accords d'abraham et
applaudi cette normalisation des
relations d'israël avec plusieurs pays
arabes
avec cette nouvelle diplomatie byden
souhaite aller à contre courant de la
politique engagée par donald trump
l'objectif rompre avec l'unilatéralisme
afin de renouer avec certaines formes de
dialogue au moyen-orient et pour en
parler nous sommes avec gérald ollivier
journaliste franco-américaine chercheur
associé à lips oeuvrons soir gérald
olivier merci d'être avec nous avant de
d'évoquer cette politique qui pourrait
changer au moyen-orient un mot tout
d'abord sur ces sondages favorables
évidemment au début de mandat souvent
pour joe biden le classique état de
grâce où une autre explication qui
serait lié à donald trump
écoutez c'est difficile à dire pour
l'instant toujours est il que joe biden
est en train de mettre en place sa
politique et c'est d'abord une politique
qui se veut en rupture avec celle de
donald trump
on l'a vu avec la série de décrets qu'il
a signé depuis une semaine dont
l'essentiel sont en fait constitue à
détricoter ce qu'avait mis en place
donald trump
alors il a des sondages favorables parce
que pour l'instant comment dirais-je il
plaît à son électorat c'est à dire que
lorsqu'il promet de régulariser 11
millions de clandestins
eh bien il plaît à l'ailé gauche du
parti démocrate qui veut des frontières
ouvertes
lorsqu'il promet ou même dans ce qu'il
fait interrompre le projet de pipeline
keystone ou qu'il suspend les permis
pour le la fracturation hydraulique ce
qu'on appelle le fracking en anglais ou
bien encore qu'il suspend les permis
d'exploration pour les énergies fossiles
il plaît à l'est l'environnementaliste
écologistes du parti démocrate et
peut-être c'est ce qu'on constate dans
les sondages
maintenant le fond de la politique n'est
pas encore en place et par contre on ne
peut pas gouverner et ernée
man par décret donc à un moment il
faudra qu'il s'arrête
il faudra que peut-être il regarde ce
qui se passe du côté du congrès où après
tout les démocrates ont une majorité
donc rien ne m'empêche de passer par le
législateur mais c'est vrai qu'à partir
de là les choses seront moins simple
alors comment justement réagissent et
républicains quand ils voient la
politique de donald trump être des prix
côté avec la sortie évidemment que l'on
sait un de leur poule a ils font profil
bas aux états unis en fait ce qui se
passe c'est que les républicains sont en
train de dénoncer un discours qui se
veut un discours inefficace heures
rappelons-nous de l'appel lancé par joe
biden il ya à peine plus d'une semaine
lors de son discours d'investiture il
dénonce ce discours avec des actes qui
eux sont plutôt provocateur
parce qu'encore une fois lorsque vous
promettez de régulariser 11 millions de
clandestins c'est un chiffon rouge qui
est agité devant les supporters de
donald trump qui étaient massivement
contre l'immigration notamment
l'immigration clandestine
lorsque vous lorsque vous interrompez un
projet comme le projet d'oléoduc
keystone vous allez contre la politique
de donald trump qui servait à relancer
le secteur de l'énergie et à relancer
des emplois industriels aux états unis
et on pourrait comme ça énumérons
d'autres décisions qui ont été prises et
qui vont à l'encontre de tout ce que les
supporters de donald trump défendent est
donc prêcher l'unité d'un côté mais de
l'autre côté prendre des décisions qui
sont interprétées comme des provocations
par 75 millions d'électeurs il ya une
contradiction fondamentale et c'est
celle qui pour l'instant est dénoncé de
manière relativement timide parce que
les républicains sont eux mêmes pris à
un autre piège dont on parlera peut être
un petit peu plus tard mais qui est
quand même soutenu est mise en avant par
un certain nombre de médias et d'élus
républicains alors la politique au
moyen-orient anthony blinken a à la
détailler aujourd'hui peut-on parler
d'une véritable remise à plat alors
qu'on sait quand même qu'il ya eu des
succès en dans ce domaine
l'ancien président trump mais justement
justement c'est votre remarque est
parfaitement justifiée on ne veut pas
forcément en donner crédit au président
trump mais il a malgré tout ouvert les
yeux alors sur la chine d'un côté mais
au proche orient il a clairement mis en
évidence je dirais les manquements de ce
compte de ce qu'on appelle le jessy pi
au est le fameux accord sur le nucléaire
iranien ou il a souligné que cet accord
n'avait pas du tout priver l'iran de
pouvoir parvenir à réaliser une bombe
nucléaire sade et simplement le retarder
donc aujourd'hui quand anthony blinken
vous parle de rétablir un dialogue avec
l'iran
il ne le fait pas sur la base qui était
celle de l'accord il le fait en
profitant de ce que la rupture donald
trump a mis en place même chose sur la
politique je dirais proche orientale il
ne remet pas en cause des accords de
brahms personne n'a le donner crédit à
donald trump
je crois qu'il a eu deux propositions
pour recevoir le prix nobel de la paix
pour ses accords peut-être que le temps
démontrera que ce sont des accords de
paix fondamentaux parce qu'ils ont
changé la donne au proche orient
mais anthony blinken le secrétaire
d'état prend bien soin de ne pas
détricoter cela est de parler d'une
nouvelle politique
alors c'est vrai plus multilatéraliste
plus porté sur le dialogue mais qui
quand même profitent de certains acquis
mises en place pendant quatre ans par
donald trump et dans l'administration
alors un autre changement sur les armes
un washington qui suspend temporairement
certains transferts et vente en cours de
matériel de défense américains comme
l'arabie saoudite et les émirats arabes
unis sauf sauf erreur de ma part que
donald trump avait passé des accords en
échange de la reconnaissance par les
émirats bhl de l'état d'israël
oui ça c'est une c'est une décision qui
en effet peut poser problème parce qu on
en revient toujours à quelque chose
qu'on avait dénoncé du temps de donald
trump
c'est à dire jusqu'à quel point les
engagements d'une administration doivent
être respectées par l'administration qui
vient après on a cela pour ceux se cette
livraison d'armes ou cet achat d'armes
comme comme vous le disiez qu'ils
portaient quand même sur 100 milliards
et qui avait contribué grandement à je
dirais facile
et et l'intercession de l'arabie
saoudite dans justement ce nouveau
processus de paix au proche orient
et là on a une administration qui fait
comme si cet accord n'existait pas donc
on a des questions à se poser sur la
continuité de la politique américaine
il fut un temps où cette continuité
était quand même plus assurée notamment
en matière de politique étrangère d'une
administration à l'autre gère le vivier
vous m'aviez invité a justement parlé de
ce piège dans lequel les républicains se
sont mis ce sera ma dernière question
quel est ce piège justement à ben le
piège c'est le piège tendu par
l'administration démocrate concernant le
procès de donald trump le procès en
destitution
c'est à dire que depuis le 6 janvier
sous prétexte de l'envahissement du
capitole par certains des supporters de
donald trump ce jour là eh bien on
dénonce aux états unis la montée d'un
extrémisme la présence de ce qu'ils
appellent des données cd terroriste
intérieure des domestiques terroristes
et on prétend aujourd'hui je dirais
nettoyer le pays nettoyer l'armée
nettoyer les villes et des provinces de
cette présence de gens qu'on assimile à
des suprématistes blancs à des
terroristes et qui sont en fait des
supporters de donald trump est en vérité
on constate avec la présence de troupes
à washington qui n'est absolument plus
justifiée l'investiture c'était il ya
une semaine
ça a fait venir 26 mille soldats je
crois que plus de la moitié sont
toujours présents à washington
on a les images d'une ville en état de
siège pour maintenir cette fiction cette
illusion qui lie à une menace et en
profiter pour faire monter un nouveau
maccarthysme et ces hamacs artistes qui
piège les républicains dans une sorte de
je dirais de paradoxes totalitaires ou
orwelliens parce que aujourd'hui à
washington
si vous dénoncez cette attaque contre
les supporters de 36 vous dénoncer ces
abus contre un certain nombre de
libertés
eh bien vous est pointé du doigt comme
ayant pris la défense de ces extrémistes
et êtes vous-même partisante cet
extrémiste donc vous êtes partisan de
vous menacer l'état et et c'est
exactement ce qui se passait dans les
années 50 avait
là car si à l'époque on prétendait
nettoyer le gouvernement de l' influence
communiste et il fallait faire passer
des tests aux employés fédéraux pour
s'assurer qu'ils n'avaient pas chez eux
des amis des connaissances qui étaient
proches du parti communiste et si
c'était le cas et bien ils étaient
évincés
et si vous vous même vous preniez la
défense de ces gens là et bien vous
étiez accusés d'être complices de ces de
ces communistes c'est exactement la même
chose à laquelle on assiste aujourd'hui
ou si vous prenez la défense des
supporters de trump on vous accuse
d'être le complice de terroristes
domestique et c'est un climat que je
considère extrêmement malsain et c'est
de ce piège là dont je parlais en
évoquant les républicains et un certain
silence par rapport à ce qui est en
train de se dérouler merci beaucoup
gérald olivier d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur arte france et c'est la fin
de cette émission se retrouve dans
quelques minutes pour 1 point complet
sur l'actualité de la journée
[Musique]
comment vous jugez maintenant la façon
dont on a géré la crise parce que c'est
arrivé cette histoire personne ne
prenait pas au sérieux nos pieds il ya
beaucoup de gens qui ont compris a pris
les choses en main mais c'est presque
inévitable que l'on met tout le monde
dans le même panier et à dire que l'âme